what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel and welcome to
the pre-game
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos as you
guys already know if you have watched
two or more of my lives and you do not
subscribe we have beef okay beef people
so before i start i have a couple
announcements the first being that we
have two clips channels the first is
just pearly clips and pearl daily thank
you guys for getting me to 70k in a
month and a half on the first clip
and the second one's at 10k we have two
different editors on these clips channel
so it's kind of cool because you get to
see different like editing styles of
clips from the show on top of that if
you want to be a part of the chat today
sign up for our five dollar memberships
on top of that our ten dollar
memberships you get to see a
behind-the-scenes look at our new
penthouse that we got yes
on top of that third tier where you get
to connect with us on social media and
fourth tier you get a one-on-one call
with me once a month on top of that go
follow my instagram it's just dot pearly
things you have to type out the whole
thing on instagram because i am shadow
band right now um fourth thing is that
they took away my first tick tock
account my second tick tock account and
my third tick tock account so go follow
justpearlythings.4 and
justpearlythings.5 because i am on my
final warning for both of those
so
justpearlythings.6 might be coming soon
um on top of that we're going to be
having a members only live in two weeks
all super chats are going towards a new
camera um blessing wants to shoot in 8k
isn't that right blessing
also if you want to get on the show dm
eddie so um today we have a lovely panel
so why don't we go around everyone say
your name your age your relationship
status and a fun fact it could be a fun
fact about you or just the fun fact you
know so you can start sure
i'm tallulah thank you for having me on
i'm 38 i'm in a relationship and my fun
fact is i went to ladies finishing
school
my name is ubi um 36 years old
fun fact
let's do an animal fact
um
nine banded armadillos always give birth
to identical quadruplets
wow wow isn't that interesting huh
there you go
[Laughter]
i learned something
i wanted to teach people something
that's one of the funnest fun facts
we've had on the show yeah i've got a
lot of fun facts but something personal
um
just so people know my background born
in england grew up in saudi arabia went
to american and british schools family
from
nigeria originally and
world traveler global nomad
is it me oh um i'm emily i'm 31
single um a fun fact is it fun
i can i can put my foot on my head is
[Laughter]
oh i'm esther i'm 26 i feel really young
um i'm single still in the streets
it's treacherous in the streets
um
my fun fact i can put my leg on my head
too girl
i know but no you're i've seen your
pictures yeah no it's not even a
competition
but yeah so it's your girl christabel um
i'm 30. um a fun oh i'm in a
relationship by the way
fun fact fun fact
i don't really know if this is a fun
fact but um
i was scared of dogs but i've currently
faced my fear i've actually got a dog so
yeah fun fact amazing
[Music]
[Laughter]
my name's auntie jenny
um she's making it
i'm gonna mix the fun facts and the age
together okay all right i used the whole
year on sunday i am 54.
hey guys i'm jess i am 28 years old and
i'm single
um
fun fact about me or just fun fact
period
um
i don't know i can't say the acl one
because i used it last time you can't
you could tell them again oh um
found out recently after i tore my
meniscus that i haven't had an acl for
one to two years
i've been playing basketball this whole
time
that's what i said wow yeah
very interesting that was the biggest
shock when you found out yeah after
surgery yeah hyped up on drugs and the
surgeon comes in yeah that black hole
back there is supposed to be acl but
there's nothing there and i'm like
i just
my
laughed
okay um so um today's special guest um
zooby
is a phenomenal athlete actually
a world world champion right now this is
how you're going to introduce me
is it wrong
no
um why don't you tell them about how you
broke the woman's deadlifting record
with ease
um yeah okay so this is going back like
three and a half years ago time flies
in february 2019 i posted a now famous
or infamous video on twitter
of me doing a
the video was a 230 kilo deadlift
and i said something along the lines of
i keep hearing about how biological men
have no strength advantage over women in
2019 so watch me destroy the british
women's deadlift record without trying
ps identified as a woman whilst lifting
the weight don't be a bigot
um
at the time i posted that i had
18 000 followers on twitter so i thought
it was going to get a couple laughs you
know a few retweets whatever
very quickly i realized that i had done
something i didn't exactly know what it
was but the video hit 10 000 views in
about 10 minutes
and it just kept growing and growing by
the time i went to bed that night it was
300 000 woke up in the morning half a
million hit a million later that day and
it just kept going and going and going
at one point i remember this i was
gaining
about a hundred followers an hour
for weeks on end so i hit 20k 30k it
kept kept on going i mean today i think
i'm at i don't know 860 000 something
twitter followers
but this video put me on the map
for millions of people
including some very high profile people
like joe rogan who's podcast i've now
been on twice uh ben shapiro candace
owens tucker carlson piers morgan
all these media figures around the world
and then so many people who have ended
up becoming fan supporters and followers
of
what i do
main thing i actually do is making music
i'm also an author i run a podcast
called real talk with zubi i'm a public
speaker
so
it's been a wild ride over these last
few years but that is how it all started
with that deadlift video so to this day
if you if you google search british
women's deadlift record i think my name
still comes up right at the beginning
and my wikipedia page so
no it looks like no woman's been able to
break that record just yet so there we
are
um so this
inspired our topic today which is our
modern women men
um and we're gonna react to um a clip
from matt walsh and i just want to get
you know since we have a full panel full
of women today um
everyone's take on it yeah
here you
with the fluidity of these things
how do i know if if i'm a woman you know
i
that's a great question i like scented
candles yeah i've watched sex in the
city yeah
um yeah
so how do i know yeah matt that question
right there like
that question
is
like when it's asked with a lot of
curiosity right that's the beginning of
a lot of people's like gender identity
development journeys if my mom who gave
birth to me is
a woman
and my wife is a woman
though i haven't asked her
maybe i should um
but if they're all women and also the
boy who sits down with you and says i
think i'm a girl
actually is one then then what is a
woman um
i'm not a woman so i
i can't really answer that
i don't care if you think you're a sheep
dog
and you come into my store
it don't matter to me just don't come in
and try to shove that [ __ ] down my
throat if it makes someone feel better
what about their feelings i don't give a
[ __ ] about them
what about the star wars universe
jar jar binks
pansexual do you think
transgender
um
why why
well it ain't true
you're not a gender studies major or are
you
no no okay how do you know that you're a
man how do i know that i guess because i
got it dead
what is a woman
why do you ask that question
i'd just really like to know
what do you think the answer to that
question is
well i'm i'm asking that's why i came to
a college professor who who's
this is your this is what you do
what other kinds of answers have you got
a lot of like this where you're not
answering i've got a lot of that so i
think it's interesting that you that you
say that some of the people you've
you've um interviewed have been um
reluctant to answer it and i think that
has a lot to do with the way the
questions that preceded it and the the
way that you've conducted yourself in
the interview how have i conducted
myself
how do you think you've conducted
yourself
you
i really don't want to answer the
questions do you
i i came today very willing and
enthusiastic about answering questions
about women and gender sexuality studies
which is so you wanted to do you wanted
to answer questions about women's
studies and so shouldn't the the first
answer you should be able to provide is
what exactly is a woman well it's it for
me it's it's actually a really simple
answer and that's a person who
identifies as a woman but what are they
identifying as as a woman
what is that
as a woman
do you know what a circular definition
is
i do
it's sort of like
what you're doing right now where a
woman is is a woman mm-hmm because
you're seeking what we would call in my
field of work and essentially
shout out to matt walsh
shout out to me okay so my first
question for the panel
is what is a woman
and why and why
don't they want to answer it and so you
can start and then go all the way around
okay uh
i believe that a woman is
a human being that is born with
certain areas of their body and their
mind that is different is completely
different to a man that's the best way
i've never even been asked that question
but
that's the best way i can describe it um
we
i believe a woman has
a different mind to a man
a different wiring and a completely
different body and um we also have a
completely different reproductive system
okay
should i go last or should i go now
no you can go now
or do you want to go i'd like to hear
the other answers okay okay then you can
go first um
to me a woman by definition would be
someone who has two x chromosomes uh and
possesses a vagina as a standard okay
that's what i'd say
oh my god i don't know
because
it can't be based on biological factors
because
like women
it doesn't matter anyway if your vagina
you know what i mean so i'm like
i guess
a woman is someone that feels like a
woman
if you feel
because i can't even say what happened
what if i where my record stands
[Laughter]
my record stands
i would say a woman is you know same
like these other ladies what they said
they've got two breasts
they've got a vagina they're able to
give birth that is a woman um and also
they've got sentimental feelings you
know
um yes a man could have a sentimental
feeling but
i feel like with men
that's more of you know than finding
their feminine side you know so
that's the difference
yeah that's what i would say okay auntie
you want to go
[Laughter]
well i hope i know who i am or what i
um
a woman's a female biological female
with a womb ovaries
no vagina
okay just yeah um
that's
essentially what auntie said is a woman
you're a biologist you're born a female
you have vagina you have breasts you
have wounds you have ovaries
and i think the reason why they don't
want to answer it is because
they want to be
politically correct or whatever and
it's frustrating because i feel like if
you ask a dude what does it mean to be a
man they'll be able to say it when it
comes to women is it what does it mean
to be a woman
well
you know and it's like
that's
it's irritating because it's like
oh i'll let it be answered
what do you think about the guys in this
that that weren't answering
are they women
the people i've seen multiple videos and
there's people that have studied women's
whatever it is within women's and you
ask them what is what you're like you
know
what is it to you it's like no we're
asking you because you've studied it so
you tell us mr professor
can i just say that i forgot that second
part of what he was asking us like why
they won't answer it yeah because
if they answered it truthfully they'll
be all out of jobs
because they're they're making money
from talking rubbish from fooling people
so
and the thing is i hate when you answer
a question with a question and that's
exactly what they did all the time so
imagine if they stood there after
teaching people you can be this by this
and this trans this and you can identify
as this and then all of a sudden they
say
we were lying
come on they're not gonna they might get
sued
you know they will ostracize and i think
that's why they don't answer because
they've been lying to people
and they don't want to tell the truth
yeah i mean shortest definition possible
a woman is an adult human female
um you've gone into more depth on
exactly what that means
2x chromosomes
female reproductive capacity womb cervix
vagina the whole plumbing
[Music]
completely different frame
um different body completely different
hormonal profile and so on to a man the
reason why those people won't answer
that question is
number one the reason why a small
percentage of people won't answer that
is because they're ideologically
captured they're ideologically possessed
by gender ideology which has
roots going back many many decades but
the majority of them won't answer it
because they're cowards
simple as that 100
simple as that
how do you how do you yeah
do you guys think bob risky and kate
caitlyn jenner are not women no no
of course not wait who are you so
caitlyn jenner was bruce jenner and then
vobrisky the nigerian fashionista is um
it was a man but now he identifies they
were born as men so they are not women
oh okay you can't change your sex i mean
personally i think they could be
whatever they want to be but you guys
are like so i have a question could i be
a dog
if i identified it as a dog and i
started saying woof woof could i be a
dog
if you identify the way the rules work
if you identify because it's the same
thing but that's a whole different
species man that's like okay can she be
black yeah okay that's my next question
apparently now you can
oh i don't know man
transracialism makes more sense than
transgenderism
you say it makes more sense i said
transracialism makes more sense than
transgenderism
how because race is actually a spectrum
race is actually a social cons gender is
binary there's male and female that's it
there's nothing else
right race is actually a spectrum right
if i were to have a child with an asian
woman my child is going to be mixed if
she is mixed and we have a child the
child is going to be
race is a
a it's actually a social construct yes
it's based on our dna and ancestral
history but these terms we use nobody's
actually black nobody's actually white
no one's actually these literal colors
right if someone is mixed race with the
fact that we even call them black
right if we call drake black or we call
barack obama black right they're just as
white as they are black but due to the
social construct we call them
black in many cases so it's actually
socially constructed and it's genuinely
a spectrum you can meet someone and
you're like okay what race are you and
it's like well i don't know like my
grandparents are from here my mom's from
here my dad's from here
you know but they're gender it's a
simple binary so
if you can
so it would make much more sense for me
to identify
as i don't know a different ethnicity
identifies jamaican or identify as
indian that makes more sense and is also
more believable than me identifying as a
woman
so if you're opening the door and you're
accepting the arguments of
transgenderism you'd also have to if
you're going to be logically and
rationally consistent you'd also have to
allow people to identify as whatever
race or ethnicity perhaps nationality
even age right it's more believable that
i'm 30 years old than it is that i'm a
woman
right so why can't i identify as 30. all
right i looked i i look like i could be
30. i feel like i could be 30.
so this is what people are opening the
doors to okay yeah i identify as 16. and
people can do what they want by the way
so um if you're an adult you can live
your life however you want right if
you're a man and you want to wear
dresses and take hormones and do
whatever you want you can but you are
never going to be a female you can't be
so for example if um
let's say pearl
today she wakes up and say oh i'm
jamaican i identify as a jamaican woman
that's acceptable
no he said he's not i'm saying it
i'm i'm saying it would make more sense
than her saying that she's a man
he's comparing the two facts i'm just
i'm sorry transgender is saying that it
makes more sense because being a race is
something we created but in terms of
being a man and a woman that's a
biological thing god created yeah
yeah so it's saying that if we humans
didn't create that someone's black
someone's white will all just be people
that's basically what yeah i mean paul
could generally i mean she might feel
black she might someone might identify
more with black culture or korean
culture or whatever
um
but that would be laughter in fact this
has been because there are people who i
do identify as transracial and people
laugh at them but then those same people
will you know scream at you if you say
that a man can't be a woman and vice
versa right and it's one thing to be
polite and kind to people and i think
this is where you're coming from from a
compassionate angle i think mine is more
i don't like people i think people are
speaking from a position of privilege
you're saying this because you've never
felt like you were something else
imagine being born i feel like i'm a dog
every day
no no
imagine like imagine like you were born
in a body knowing that for you to come
out you're gonna take a lot of abuse
people were killed for this i just don't
believe that people were doing it just
for the sake of it i do think that's how
they've done you think that society has
a part to play would it don't not if
you're getting killed for it
but in terms of like thinking oh yeah
i'm a man or i'm a woman
also to go back to the trans-racial
thing
people black people were killed and
people want to be black it's like what
what does that have to do with them
infinitely more people have been killed
for being black than
but how is that different from just
going off of his example and him
explaining race and transgender people
people been killed for everything so
that should we start being oh okay all
right and
then stuff is going to happen like this
like a video we're about to watch where
a teacher shows up how the teacher shows
up and it's just like oh it's okay
she's
she's trans yeah and by the way
gender dysphoria absolutely exists there
are absolutely people who feel like they
are in the wrong body or feel like they
identify more with the opposite sex that
exists right i'm not i'm not questioning
that but you know there are people who
are anorexic and they're extremely
skinny and they think that they're fat
yeah right they believe that they are
fat they have an image disorder in their
brain you think it's a mental disorder
yes yes yes
if you literally believe that you are
something that you're not
what else do we do we call that if if i
believed that i was to use pearls and
example a dog and i might i could j i
could genuinely believe that by the way
have you ever have you heard of body
integrity dysmorphia this is a real
thing body integrity dysmorphia is when
people feel like they should be missing
a limb or they feel like they should be
disabled and to feel whole to feel that
their true self they'll go and they'll
amputate an arm or amputate a leg
because they feel like their body is not
they feel like they're supposed to be
disabled and they can go and amputate a
limb that that's a disorder
right that's a disorder there's people
who've intentionally blinded themselves
because they identify as a blind person
and they go so far as actually
chemically subjective yes i know you
guys see a man and a woman as an
objective thing because that's what you
were saying biologically you're either a
man or a woman i personally don't think
so okay show me show me someone who's
neither
show me show me the person who's not a
man or a woman i mean you can go out on
the street right now and see literally
watch the next ten thousand people walk
past you can identify with one hundred
percent accuracy whether it's being a
woman is not about what you look like
though it you could it is you could look
like a man because maybe you're a tomboy
so say a woman i was a tomboy
exactly yeah but that's it could appear
to you as a man that's what i'm trying
to say it's not about the appearance
it's not about you i've played 12 years
of basketball i know some pretty but
and you could still tell they were girls
they're still girls
yeah they're still girls if you you can
look at any cell in their body it'll be
have xx chromosomes right you could look
at their skeleton you could look at
their reproductive organs
any or all of the above that's my point
being a woman is not just about your
physical it's not just about your
biological okay what's your definition
then i can't i can't even like define it
because like how did you find yourself
if someone asked you how do you know
you're a woman but i'm different to
other women that i've like that i felt
maybe like a man that felt like he was a
woman and then like transformed i'm
different to that because me i was born
as a woman okay and i would say
i how do you know
well i have a i believe
i believe like three times do men do
what about three times once
you know i i think even even that in
itself that defines a woman doesn't it
has a man
have you ever had a man ever had a
period in a menstrual cycle show me one
there's there's there's eight billion
people in the world just show me one
i don't know it's never happened
okay
this is hard
to say something if you if you had
skipped a period for whatever reason
yeah or like you didn't have a period
for six months but you weren't pregnant
would that make you feel like a guy
because you haven't had a period
no
okay
i i just so it's not about bleeding
that's your you've literally just made
the point it's not about that no it's
not just about that it's it's it's like
you can't conceptualize a woman that's
what i'm trying to say
you can
adult
human
female
anyone trying to steal my sex or my
gender you shouldn't be right so i would
not say i was a tomboy growing up
not once that i think i was a man
not one said i want to be a man
but i was a tomboy growing up
and i
it pisses me off
that people are going to come and
they're going to try and steal my gender
and they're going to try and say that
they're the same as me i call it
i call it gender blackface i don't care
[Laughter]
whether they're offended yeah i'm
offended that they want to tell me who i
am yeah
these are we can't tell them who they
are
i am 54 years old i'm not going to get
to this age and somebody told me that
you know what makes you a woman jennifer
mm-hmm
that's crazy yeah i mean i think it's
like well i'll be straight up i think
it's misogynistic and i don't want a man
standing next to me and he's going to
put on a dress i don't know if he's got
bigger boobies than me where he's cut
his dick off as far as i'm concerned
you're not the same as me no and it's
amazing
and you can't tell me that i'm anything
than a female i hate all these all these
other um
different terminologies for who i am
no i'm a female birthing person i'm a
woman or is it psy or whatever they call
it i don't know
that's it
because that is not who i am i'm a
female i'm a woman and they've i mean
they've got hermaphrodites they're very
rare yeah you know even then as far as
i'm concerned if you've got a woman you
can bleed in your hermaphrodite cut your
dick off there's no hermaphrodites in
the human species you can't exist you
can actually give birth
you know what that's like
that's what i said
once you've got a womb you're a woman as
far as i'm concerned they've got five
as far as you've got a womb you're a
woman as far as i'm concerned even if
you've got both and you've got a womb
you can give birth that makes you a
woman so that's the difference between a
man and a woman is that a woman has a
womb if you ain't got a womb you're not
a woman as far as i'm concerned so what
about the women that can't reproduce
that's they're not necessarily that's
the reason we don't have a woman that's
a rarity and that's an exception and
these people are extremely rare
they're still adult they're still adult
human females we're talking about the
majority they're talking about the
majority and as far as i'm concerned no
womb no woman
i feel like i feel like you know you
know what we're saying and you know that
we're right but you just kind of like to
argue a little bit not really i think i
i i have a lot of i've been around
people that have explained how they felt
and don't get me wrong like i i don't
really i wouldn't really like my child
to say oh i'm a transgender and i i was
really pissed off when caitlyn jenner
won the woman of the year because
that really pissed me off because i've
been a woman you know what i mean like
they're women doing amazing things and
you're going to give it to a man
he was a man and then when he
transformed into a woman so then why are
you mad no no but i don't it's a woman
he hasn't even been a woman for that
long but he's a woman and he hasn't even
done it but wait i thought
i thought you said in the beginning that
it's anyone that feels like a woman no
no but i'm saying the fact that you won
the woman of the truth yeah but that's
my problem with that right but i'm
saying why would you have a problem
because there are other women that have
done a lot of things and for a long time
but
she's done stuff you know i mean
caitlyn caitlin jenner broke records i'm
sure if it was the women's division
identified as a man yeah
in our turf until you've done the
footwork then you can be like oh i've
done this as a woman then you can win
the woman of the year i mean he i think
he's done the work you see him recently
he's had some surgery no you guys no i
think it's just i just don't like people
telling people what they can be and what
they can't be so as long as you're not
hurting anyone well again you can you
can you can you can do what you want
with you you can do what you want
you can do what you want with your body
but the problem is when you start
letting people live in delusion they
start to think their delusion is reality
and so that's that's when you see like
like they're taking away titles from
women yeah and so like i'm an athlete i
played basketball for like i don't even
know anymore 15 20 years i don't even
know but like like to think that someone
could just transition and take away a
title is mad yeah and it takes away
opportunities for real women by the way
i think it's important to note that all
of the negative downstream repercussions
of this entire cultural psychosis
only impact women
right only impact women men are not
worried about women transitioning into
men and taking their sports record or
being in their
changing rooms or being put in they're
not concerned about females entering
male prisons and so on the same is not
the true the other way around why
because the sexes are different and
everyone knows it you may have i don't
know if you know this do you know that
there are males who are identifying as
women getting transferred into female
prisons and suddenly female prisoners
are getting pregnant how do you think
that is happening
let's put this let's put this together
right and it's women who are being put
at risk from this right it's women who
are getting their records broken by
wonderful ladies such as myself
it's women who are losing their college
scholarships for for sports who are
having
men
with their penises and testicles out in
their spas in their changing rooms so on
and so forth all the negative impacts
are on women as far as i'm concerned the
people
i mean it's not
affected you yet but the way things are
going they will wait until they start
taking away your rights as a woman yeah
and saying there are rights because
we're women or if you have a daughter
you know and she has to then compete and
she's sporty and has to now compete
against boys and the thing is is that i
remember growing up years ago and
i didn't know there was a
i think she was a lady
and her daughter
i could have been a man
so many years ago but she though she had
the operation and she changed
i never knew
as far as i'm concerned that was just i
think it was her dad and she was a woman
before but whatever she had
transgendered into whether it's a
daughter or a man but it wasn't like oh
yes you know i'm now a man and i need
these rights and i need those rights and
i need this no
it was just she just got on with her
life she didn't ask anything of anybody
she didn't try and ram
her
sexuality or her gender down people's
throats
as far as i'm concerned if that's what
you want to go and do go and do it but
don't tell me who i am i don't make it
affect my life yeah and don't try and
influence children society and everybody
else with it that's how you want to be
but i'm the same with everybody whether
you're gay or my best friend's gay he's
gay that's his business
but he's not going to try and rabbit
down my throat or anything like that
yeah
that's down to him you're allowed to
believe whatever you want to believe
whether some people think it's absurd or
not you're not allowed to force other
people to believe and accept that yeah
right this goes for absolutely
everything it goes way beyond this issue
this is our understanding of religious
beliefs political beliefs social beliefs
culturally everyone is allowed to
believe what they want
there's billions of people in the world
we don't we don't all share the same
belief systems
but if i were to come and now try to
force all the things that i believe on
someone else i can believe that this
this table is circular and yellow i have
a right to believe that i don't have a
right to try to force everyone else in
this room and everyone else in the world
to to believe
and accept and say that this table is
circular and yellow when they can see
its rectangular and black right so i
have a right i have a right to believe
that i can believe i can believe
whatever i want i can believe that i'm a
goat i can believe i'm a chicken i can
walk around on all fours and eat out of
a dog bowl if i want i can do that i
have the right to do that i can't force
everyone else to someone might be super
polite and you know pet me and treat me
like a dog or a goat or whatever you
know
right
if they want to but i can't i can't
force people to right if someone is like
no that's that's a man walking around
pretending to be a go that's not a goat
right and that could hurt my feelings if
i genuinely believe i'm a goat but if if
this ever happens by the way please like
get me some help um but just using these
examples but yeah you you can believe
whatever you like but the problem with
this issue and why it's become such a
contentious issue is because it's gone
far beyond people just living their
lives and doing what they want to do
it's got into an ideological movement
where they are now trying to force
people to believe and comply with it
oftentimes at the threat of punishment
someone said that why are they not
answering that question someone said
because they'll get fired
right that's coercion right if you are
not allowed to say something that is
factually correct and true
because you're worried about losing your
job you're not in a good place in
society that actually happened recently
than if you followed the news um the
irish teacher you think he was catholic
and he refused to refer to one of his
students as they
and actually lost his job yeah and then
because he was up in arms about it
understandably he went back to his job
his place of work the school he's worked
in for the past half many years and
tried to re-enter the school you got
arrested yeah it's a real thing in
canada it's illegal to so-called
misgender somebody but they didn't care
about his religion over that do they
they didn't put you know the fact that
he's catholic and he has strong beliefs
that actually became underneath someone
wanting to be called they yeah but is
that not not you're not considering that
other person's feelings i don't care
about that person
their feelings don't matter their
feelings don't matter you're saying that
they shouldn't impose their beliefs on
you but refusing to call someone that
what they identify as i don't remember
he's a catholic
no
handsome
and wonderful and successful those are
my preferred adjectives
right
you will hurt my feelings if you don't
refer to me as jacked handsome
intelligent charming and so
i don't have you have a right to freedom
of speech i don't have a right to
control your language
that's not how it works there's no
there's no right to not have your
feelings hurt there's no right to
control other people's language the
right is on the other side
so
yes people should be
polite and kind and civil within reason
but actually if you are now trying to
control someone else's language and
force them to call you something
especially something that you are not
you don't have a right to do that at all
at all that's not all right if i turned
around and i said to you
from today i'm gonna be a virgin
right yeah hey there there are some of
those they're born again i'm going to be
a virgin now yeah and everybody has to
identify me as a virgin and forget about
don't worry about the three
grandchildren and my 36 year old son
i'm gonna be a virgin and i'm not gonna
and anybody else who says to me that i'm
not a virgin i'm gonna sue them i'm
going to go to the newspapers and i'm
going to make me up in arms because i am
now identifying as a virgin
and i and i said to you you have to see
me as a virgin would you feel happy
about that
but i think we keep creating examples
that are not very relative to this
conversation
obviously being a virgin that is a very
objective thing
someone identifying as a man or woman
we've not been able to identify it we've
not been able to
explain what a man and a woman is if
there was
everyone else has
well you guys have because you have one
way of thinking that you've decided can
i ask can i ask you a question can i ask
you a question honestly when did you
start believing what you're saying now
when i started listening to people
no no no honestly when when like when
specifically did you start i would say
i to be fa i've always grown up with
that belief of let people be whatever
they want to believe and let me explain
okay i'm a minority right being black in
the uk especially
i know how hard it is when the majority
think that you are in the wrong and
maybe that is that compassion that i
have for them because we are the
majority we have the privilege because
we were born as our gender so we have
the privilege to say no that's how you
everyone was born as their gender no no
it's the gender that we identify as but
my point is that we are the privileged
to be able to say that that is our
identity however some people don't have
that and i feel like being a minority
and knowing what it feels like for
somebody to be like no you're less than
or no exactly no
let me finish okay someone's saying
that's the way it should be
no i have a problem with that because
well no if i was on the other foot and i
was born as a as a man and i want to
identify as a woman i would be pissed
off if somebody told me that i can't be
what i want to be nobody's saying
nobody's saying that nobody's saying
that but you are because if i'm i'm not
i'm saying you are not object you are
objectively not that thing if you if you
were sitting here telling me that you
are white
right i'll be like you're you're not
white you you can say that you are you
can feel like it you can act like it
whatever that means you could even go
and bleach your skin you could you could
do whatever you like you have the right
to do that you're an adult you have the
right to do whatever you want you can
have cosmetic procedures you can do what
you like but you are not you're not
white objectively you're you're not
like that that's the thing you don't
identify this identifying thing
it opens up an entire
pandora's box of anything because you
could you can identify as as anything
right and as i said i support someone's
right to live their life as they want to
i'm not going to treat i know more trans
just because i know so many people
period i know more trans most people
don't know any transgender people i know
multiple transgender people i know right
um
and i will treat any human being with
respect and dignity and civility what i
will not do is distort the truth and lie
to
make someone
feel happy and you don't and you don't
need to do that right you can you can
you can respect people and be kind and
be honest and also protect the truth
but is it the truth though that's what
i'm trying to say because how do you we
humans are so complex but see i agree
with you but this is why 11 is not the
truth no
no in reality it's normal no it's not
it's
critical no it's it's not it's not
hypocrite the reason i ask why you i i'm
assuming you only started believing what
you're saying quite recently
i personally i've never really i don't
know when i started believing it i think
i've always just grown up with like i
said be whatever
you're not hurting anybody when you when
you were 15
okay i don't think i ever thought about
it okay i guess the conversation is
coming up a lot more of course and i
decided i'm not going to tell someone
how they feel i'm not going to do that
because what who am i to tell you that
you're not a woman wait
the same person you are to say that this
table is not circular and yellow that's
that's objective we humans can't be
objective in every in everything that we
do we can't be objective we're too
complex can i just say okay you was
bringing up about being black and how
you're used to people you know you're
raised being black and being down
children so you understand how they feel
you didn't choose to be black
that's the way you are
they're choosing to change their sex
that's not why they believe that i don't
care whether they believe i can believe
that i'm white
the self-identity thing does not work it
doesn't work
there's so many different things oh and
then you can turn around and say that i
can say that i'm white i'm speaking like
this what am i going to get called
coconut but nothing's going to
change is this
height i mean some some men are you know
five foot four and they'd much rather be
six foot four can a man identify as six
foot four he could genuinely feel he
could be very confident and i feel like
i'm in the wrong body i'm six foot four
but you are objectively not six foot
four you can feel like that judge by
like the way you look we can actually
like measure you huh you don't look six
foot four okay but couldn't it could it
come in you can't yeah
you can we can take a cell from any part
of a woman's body and look at it
under a microscope and you can see xx
chromosomes on chromosomes that's a
woman absolutely besides yeah but that
gentleman that gender person don't look
like a woman
are you are you questioning
are you questioning that it's not
chromosomes no no i'm not saying that
it's i just think that's a factor of as
a woman i think some people yeah you can
be a man you can have the xx chromosome
and guess what you could grow up being
more masculine than anyone but that
doesn't make you doesn't make you a man
a man you can be a masculine woman you
can be a feminine man
just because you have your ex white
questions
i don't want to be broke but sometimes i
am
[Laughter]
just because you didn't have the x y
chromosome just like just because you
can't reproduce
doesn't like it doesn't okay
can i ask a question
why would it be important to that person
for me to
believe and so-called affirm
their delusion validation delusion
because you keep calling it a delusion
that's the problem if i came in here
let's be real if i said that i was six
foot five mm-hmm right
no no if i said i am six foot five i am
okay and i insist on it and i get
triggered i get mad i'm trying to get
everyone to say i am six foot five
right am i is that is that a delusion
yes
yeah but is that is that is that what is
is that me being reasonable i might be
am i being the reasonable one by trying
to force everyone to accommodate that is
that me being reasonable um are they
being unreasonable by by saying no
you're not but you can measure that you
can tell very easily if someone is male
or female with 100 accuracy if i walked
in here and said i identify as you're 26
right i identify as being 26.
that like you can't measure but i could
just go around and by the way and by the
way that's much more believable than you
say you're a man yeah but you know but
so i could identify and say look you
know i feel
more that i'm i'm your age i'm 26 like
my brain could be living in the past of
i'm 26. it's registered on my birth
certificate just the same as being a
female is
and by the way there is such a thing as
uh you know biological age in terms of
your health and other factors so
you can
be 40 years old but sort of have a
biological age of 32 say if you're in
very good shape and so on so again we
could argue that can i just make a point
to that sure when
birth certificates were created and
identifying as men and women
we haven't really understood humans
we're only understanding things now
you've got things what are you okay
who being gay was considered mental what
do you what do you mean by understanding
humans like what does that mean we had a
one way of thinking about things so
because your ex white chromosome you
have a vagina you're a woman but now
we're starting to see that that's not
the case we need to adapt okay we need
to adapt
so many people
what do we want them to do no are we
just gonna say all of them have mental
conditions
if i started going around and saying i
am black i am black you wouldn't think
something's wrong with me you wouldn't
think i'm delusional yeah but that's
categorized what do you mean male and
female as a category we have bathrooms
male and female
like what if what if i use that same
argument what if i use that same
argument okay and i said well all
throughout all of history we've known
what black and white is and now today
we're gonna change it and now i am black
can i just help something if you was on
a sinking ship and they said women and
children first are trans
you know this happened in ukraine really
yeah because you know in ukraine the men
were not allowed to leave oh yeah
right and there were
men who identified as women
who were trying to leave and they were
like no
you're staying at me and you're staying
and fighting they're like [ __ ] and they
said
women and children first
and somebody identifies big butch
identifying woman says
hey i'm before you
how would you feel like i don't know the
person would you so every question every
question is
[Laughter]
you're a mother
you got children
and they're in they're in school
and
they're teaching about transgender and
your child your son comes home and says
right mom i need the girls school
uniform for us today i'm identifying as
a girl we talked about gender and i
realized i don't want to be a boy i
don't want to wear trousers i want the
girls school uniform little pretty
philly socks and
i'm now a girl mum
i mean it will be very difficult for me
to understand but i will be open-minded
enough to understand why my child has
come to that decision i think just being
closed-minded to it completely that is
not allowing people to live i disagree
with that
it's not being closed-minded because
there's a don't go to school like that
would you allow your son to wear a dress
to school
initially probably not can i just say
why not because i grew up in a very
traditional household is that being
closed-minded though yeah i do think
being traditional is quite close-minded
because you're not trying to understand
people i'm not saying i'm so for it like
be transgender i'm just saying i am
willing to learn i am willing to listen
to how you feel why you feel it i want
it to be more studies i want us to be
more so i have a good question but at
what cost at what cost so so so okay
okay okay okay okay okay okay okay okay
okay okay thank you
um okay so at what cost and what i mean
by that is okay it starts with you just
say their gender pronouns when you meet
them right and you just treat them as
the opposite like
i don't know whatever they're pretending
to be that day
but but would you be cool with them
playing in women's sports
transgen and then what if what if
now we don't have women's sports because
athletes does my deadlift record hold i
mean in terms of that i do think there
should be a whole different category for
them just because i think it's quite
unfair for a man
that now identify as a woman to then
say that you want to do so
i don't know but because we've already
had a long-standing um definition in
terms of sports like like the way that
you participate in terms of hormones as
well men are stronger
so this is a woman
plus it takes the hormone i'm not saying
if they're completely like a man or a
woman i think they should just be we
should just allow them to be understood
so creating a whole new category for
transgender i'm for that because you
know what that's what they feel like so
compete with us but that's not what they
want because they want to be accepted
100 and affirmed 100
as women and if you're going to do that
you now have no rational argument to
prevent that male who identifies as a
woman from competing in women's sports
because that's now a woman i mean i
think there definitely needs to be more
studies because nintendo told me what
study do you need like i'm sorry
i'm
i just feel like i just feel like like
what study do you need like what i don't
give a damn what study they put in front
of me if i see a dude that's six four
jacked and looks like a dude acts like a
dude walks like a dude talks like a dude
and then competing in the women's
swimming category i don't need a study
to tell me that's a dude
that are very feminine no no
it doesn't matter
it doesn't mean that they're women no
but that's the point that i'm i'm just
trying to say that it's not one way you
keep using an example of a man that's
jacked that wants to be a woman what
about a very feminine i've met some guys
that are way more feminine than me and
i'm like oh my god like even their body
is shaking they're not women
like okay but you can james let's take
james charles
you could still tell it's a dude just
because he's feminine he's got even the
hourglass like like shape but it's still
he's still a dude
even though he's a feminine dude would
you be happy with
a man that identified as a woman having
all the same rights that you have as a
female every single right that you have
as a female would you be happy that a
man who's identifying as a woman can
just turn around they've had the
operation i've got all the same rights
as you
every single one
all the rights that you have as a female
and they're going to go up against you
as a as a as a
born female as a gender female they're
going to go up against you in everything
and they expect the same rights as you
as a female all the same rights that you
have as a female but i don't even think
women have such amazing rights anyways
we live in a very misogynistic oh no we
do not we do we do
the great benefits that we have as women
is that they make a child in terms of
when it comes to court cases they're
more likely to get the child but really
what does what does a woman have that's
women are bailed out women are literally
bailed out of every bad decision that we
make like every single one if we sleep
around there's birth control if we
if we get pregnant there's abortion if
we don't want to get abortion if we
don't want if we don't want to get an
abortion and we want to live off of the
government they'll pay for our housing
like literally every bed if we're
homeless there's women's shelters
there's not men's shelters they're just
homeless you're just talking about
abortion so that whoever is that jenna
whoever he is
if he announced
now that he's pregnant and he wants an
abortion
how would you feel about that
i literally have nothing against that i
just feel like how does that affect my
life it affects me in no way did you
hear what i said it may not affect you
now no it may not happen why would it
ever affect me i'm not saying i'm trying
to i have a question
wait okay
can i ask you a question can i ask a
question
exactly
can i ask a question
do you think that
do do you believe that objective truth
exists
to an extent yeah
okay do you think it's important
yeah okay
if
if as a society we start to reject
objective truths do you think this leads
down to a concerning pathway at all
if we if we categorically reject
objective truth in order to accommodate
the feelings of a very very very tiny
proportion of people do you not see how
that cascades into many other problems
some of which we've already talked about
but many further down the line
which we probably cannot even fathom at
this point
and that's how it all started yeah
right so
so i would be arguing just as vehemently
about if someone was coming here telling
me that two plus two equals five
i would be arguing as vehemently in
defense of the fact that two plus two
equals four not because i'm super
enthusiastic about mathematics but
simply because it is truth
right and to deny that truth
once you break that
and you say that that doesn't matter and
it's more important to allow someone to
make two plus two equals five or for
everybody to accommodate that
you've now the the problems downstream
of that now
are going to be
numerous and
and extremely chaotic we're now living
in a world where truth is
just being rejected and if you can do it
on one issue you can do it on many other
things
and i mean in terms of like identifying
as an animal i think that is
a bit too much for me why but why
there's people out there
isn't that closed-minded
why not be more open-minded say i'm
completely against it i'm just saying
that it's too much like
why no but why but i think when it comes
to humans that you want to be another
like type of human i think
why not no no wait wait no wait i'm very
i'm curious please explain to me why you
think identifying as an as another
species is too much why
well first of all i guess you can't even
use the reproduce
it's just weird it's weird you don't
think it's weird to chop your dick off
you don't think that's weird it's like
you can be born with both it just it
just shows my new number and that's and
that's and that's a different yeah but
transgender it's not like there's an
amazing
stopless amount of transgenders but the
point is they are there they're there
just like you can have a vagina why
why do you think that it's possible that
you can want to change to a woman okay
so it's like we have to just try and
understand it yeah just say right okay
can i just the percentage
of transgender people
they must take a minority
of the world
why are we giving them so many rights
you but earlier on you mentioned that's
the same as race
look how far forward they're pushing us
before they push the black race thing
before the freedom and effort look how
far how far how many hundreds of years
they were saying into slavery and all
that
but all of a sudden
this small minority is kicking up stink
within the last what 10 years they're
coming on and everybody's getting
confused and you're going towards that
mm-hmm
because white people are also
transgender no it's what that's that's
got to that's to do with power
the person with the most
the person with the most power is going
to get what they want but now
the least power is getting what they
want because they're confusing people
especially people like you that's so
easily molded and easily make it
believable these are the small minority
tiny minority who now was coming over
like they're the majority
and that's the problem because i'm sure
that years ago you weren't thinking like
this all of a sudden you start listening
that's what they want you to do
that's what they want and the fact that
they're confusing the children as well
yeah that is what is peeing me off but
you see i'm a mother of two
she's a child to me considering my son
so as far as i'm concerned they're
starting confusing the children already
otherwise
if she doesn't know who she is what a
woman is
then what chance do we spend for your
children my grandchildren and that's why
it needs to stop because they've started
with like the older they get into you
and now they want to get into the
schools yeah so according to how you're
thinking it should be okay to go into
the schools and to be teaching i think
one of the schools brought it up earlier
on it was on the news that they didn't
want to teach them sex education i can't
remember what children as young as five
yeah and now i want to do about
transgender and all these different
genders with sex education it's a joke
for school children and that's what i
said to you earlier on if your child
came home and said well mom
i know i want to be a girl
and as far as i and by your way of
thinking
the children in school
everybody should be allowed to feel who
they want to feel they should allow to
be who they want to be
so why can't your son wear a dress and
shoes tomorrow and have his hair in bows
and by the way i hope you know that
there are parents in this country in
canada and in the usa who have lost
custody of their own children for
refusing to affirm their gender
confusion
lost custody to their own children
the state the government has stepped in
and taken control of that situation
and decided that because their dad or
mom said no
you are not this thing you're saying you
are you're you're confused they've
stepped in under the guise of so-called
child abuse because they if this is this
is the gateway that's being opened and
that's the way it's going and that's the
logical procession
of these ideas so i've said many times
i'm a big defender of people's rights
but your rights do not include
the right to trample other people's
rights or the right to force people to
believe things they don't believe or say
things they don't want to say and so on
as soon as you're trying to do that
you're the one who's out of order
because i would never try to force i
have a lot of strong beliefs in this
world right but i am not trying to
force them upon anyone i will even say
something look you are allowed to
believe that you're a man in a woman's
body you're allowed to believe you're a
woman you're allowed to believe
whatever you want i do not i'm not
compelled you don't have a right to make
me
validate that you you just don't right i
don't i don't even have a right like i'm
a male i'm a he i don't have a right to
make you call me
a he yeah right like
i can't just say just like i can't say
okay these are the adjectives i like to
be referred by this is how i see myself
i see myself a lot of ways i identify as
many things but it's up to someone else
whether they want to also
agree that they identify me as those
things and to refer to me as that and so
can i just ask are you okay with
homosexuals
so what does that mean
a what homosexuals oh i thought you said
something
[Laughter]
are you okay with homosexuals what does
that mean that's just do you mean okay
with it i know what a homosexual is but
what do you mean by okay okay so are
they okay to decide that they like
someone of the opposite sex but they
don't affect our lives of course they
are it's a free world
oh okay so you can be gay but you can't
change your gender when did i say that
that's what i'm trying to do
you cannot literally change your sex
it's not possible just like just like
you can't fly
you you you can't change your sex
it's not possible okay so you define
your gender with the chromosome purely
the chromosomes
yeah it goes it goes beyond chromosomes
we've said
you know there are there's chromosomes
there's our reproductive our
reproductive wiring there's our hormonal
profiles there's our physiques
everything from our skeleton to our body
mass and so on there are many
differences between males and females by
the way not just in the human species
across the entire animal kingdom
it's a binary thing right every single
person who exists in this world was
birthed by a woman
with no exceptions but that's the same
conversation they had with homosexuals
because
no let me let me finish i didn't say
because the the recurring conversation
is because a man and a woman can
reproduce so how can you like someone of
the same sex because you can't reproduce
and that's the same conversation they
had this was the um
the defense that people would always say
to them no you're no it's like what's
the major difference
i can explain easily your sexual
preference i can explain this very
easily it's not even a hard question
okay
a homosexual is
if a male who is attracted to males yeah
that's a gay man right a woman who is
attracted to a female who's attracted
other females is a lesbian woman okay
these are these are just objective
okay if a female says that he if a
female says that she is a male or a male
says that
that he is a female
that is
you this is not objective reality
they're not even in the same sphere
objective just saying that you're
attracted to some some like your
opposite sex that's not objective that's
something that you actually have to
understand that person and i should be
like no wait why is the sexual power
there are
it's objective reality that there are
men who are attracted to men and there
are women who are attracted to women
because we're so forward thinking now no
no no no no no people didn't want to
know but it's always whether or not they
accepted it it existed yeah but just
like it always existed transgender
always existed it's just now we're
having the conversation no no it didn't
no it doesn't
no the feeling that you feel like you
are gender dysphoria that's gender
dysphoria you want to categorize it
that's what it's called that's lit by
definition this is what it's called
transgenderism is gender dysphoria
exists i've i've said that
there are males who feel
like they identify more as the opposite
sex there are females who feel they
identify you know i agree with you that
exists there's people that actually tran
um
they change into women and then five
years down the line they're like
actually it's the worst thing i've ever
done i want to be a man now there's a
job as a child that is
dysphoria yeah
it's a dysphoria other people
they aren't there there are many people
there are people that that's how they
feel and they continue in that line and
i've never you see you're the thing is
you're arguing against points i'm not
making
i've never at any point said that
someone is not allowed
to do that or someone is not allowed to
believe that or there are not people who
genuinely feel that way yeah i am simply
saying
just because you feel
you are something does not make you that
thing i can't just say just because you
feel like you're attracted to the
opposite sex
no it's because naturally no naturally
you shouldn't be attracted to the
opposite sex no naturally even in the
bible it talks about eve even when it
comes to
yeah but like the point the point you're
gonna make is is he's not even
disagreeing with you he's saying there
are people that feel like they should be
met like women that feel like they
should be men and men that feel like
they should be women but throughout
history they couldn't they would they
weren't we didn't have trans there
weren't people doing the surgeries and
stuff yeah so that's that's a new one
yeah or the hormones that's a new thing
so we should thank god that now we have
the technology to do that should we
are you in a relationship right now no
okay
place yourself in a relationship with a
man
your dream your dream man dream house
dream whole thing right
and
you're planning a wedding
kids
you're like i've got my dream life
and he turned around to you at dinner
one night and said
i feel
that i
i'm getting feelings that i identify
more as a woman
and
i am going to
pursue looking at um you know speaking i
don't know speaking to a therapist and
potentially getting surgery
um will you support me
and stay with me
and can we still have a family
what would you do well i wouldn't stay
with him because i'm not attracted i i
like straight heterosexual men i mean
forever yeah but you just said you just
said hang on hang on you just said you
just said that we have to be more
accepting
we have to understand
so this is your this is your boyfriend i
am not saying that you're saying you
don't have to understand him but you
have to understand everyone else stand
him and not be sexually attracted to him
i can say you know what i'm gonna be i'm
gonna help you be a part of this process
sexually i don't want to even help him
okay
i have a question i have a question i
have a question
what if are we going to ask the same
question i feel like we think that's
right
go ahead josh go ahead
you said you're attracted to
straight
men what if
this man that's transitioning to a woman
still likes women he's still considered
a straight man
so would you stay
but i like a man that looks like a woman
is not going to look like a woman
because to me sometimes you want a man
that looks like a man what if he has
like short hair just like a bob doesn't
wear makeup natural look still looks
like a man was like i identify as a
woman
so what's making you a woman if you're
not trying to look like a woman feeling
you tell me he feels he just feels that
way
you told me it's not about looks he told
us it's not about lips to look like a
woman if he's saying you know what i'm i
still look like a man
and
i feel like a woman
i guess because i see you as a man i
can't really i guess the sexual
attraction is still there so what if
okay i have a question so what if
you're dating a guy okay
you're super happy same situation right
and instead of him transitioning
he tells you i used to be a girl oh that
was another question
do you care you probably would have
noticed but yeah
yeah guys
he had the best surgery just because i
want to understand them does not mean
i'm attracted to it it doesn't mean
sexually i want to be with someone like
that it just means i'm okay with you
experimenting understanding
but that's the same thing zoopy was
saying he's saying i don't care what you
do you can do what the hell ever you
want but that doesn't make what you're
doing real well so
and i think and i think that's something
and i think on some level you know this
and this is and like i just i don't know
if you like to argue or what because
because
you know deep down that bruce like bruce
jenner caitlyn whatever it is didn't
deserve that award like there's there's
something in you that knows this
but but it's like you're you just like
to argue i don't know what it is to me
it just
it seems like either you know some trans
people and you're worried about
affecting maybe you've got some friends
that are trans or you know trans people
and that you're frightened of do you
know where it is i feel like because
we're in a podcast already and we've
kind of touched on this subject and we
got a lot of backlash for it because i
was more outspoken about it but esther
was more like sitting on the fence about
it you know like oh no so i feel like
she's trying to protect people's
feelings that's what i feel like you're
not actually speaking your truth yeah
because you know what i think okay i'll
be honest this is probably and i'm gonna
be completely honest i grew up in a very
christian traditional home i remember
when i was deeply into god
i used to tell homosexuals that
basically they're going to hell
and
honestly
back then i believed that that was the
truth you are going to hell because you
are basically attracted to someone of
the same sex and i remember someone i
was in school with
i he i used to upset him a lot and i
didn't realize how upset he was because
of the words that i say to him but i
couldn't help it because i'd go to
church my pastor would stop preaching
about homosexuals and how can i have a
question when did your mind um because
zooby kind of asked us earlier but when
did your mind change on this stuff i
would say maybe when i became a a lot
less religious
and i started to think about was it in
university possibly
um no i actually i went to china
actually i remember going to china and
in china the major thing that they have
is they renounce all religion so they
don't um they basically are against
christians muslim and all that and i
think i liked the way that everyone was
so yeah i don't care and i think that re
because i was with a lot of like
christians muslim and they were all like
yeah christian is the right way and they
were like no it's allah and i really
thought that was quite ignorant to not
listen to people and think your way is
the right way and i think it made me
start to really take things back to and
i thought about that guy that i really
upset because that was generally my
truth but then now i look back at here
i'm like
how the hell yeah but you're saying that
you upset that guy how about them
upsetting us women but he's not done
anything to upset us real women they're
not upsetting us though i think
thomas when she won the when he he won
the women's like swimming title whoever
the hell was in second place i'm sure
she was upset
but that's what happens when you let
people live in delusion i know women who
have lost competitions to male athletes
but i think that
if they want to like basically
participate in women's sports then maybe
they should start testing the
testosterone level it's not enough i i
think
that's just music
because even in the even ones where they
do the test
you are still allowed to have four times
the level of a biological female and
compete i i don't think people neces i
don't think a lot of most people
understand just how much more
testosterone men have than women do and
testosterone is not the only difference
we have different bodies we have
completely different bodies right if
anthony joshua usain bolt myself even
went on suppressed our hormones for one
years two years three years we still
have our physical frames yes you'd lose
some muscle mass but you're still as
tall as you are you still have a bigger
lung capacity you still have larger
hands bigger bones so on and so forth
there are many many differences it's not
just the hormones and you can't suppress
to a level when if if someone goes
through this gender transition and they
take the hormones you actually cannot
lower it to such a level as to that of a
biological female because if you do you
develop osteoporosis
right because you your body your body
cannot take it so much uh so much
calcium i believe has leached from your
bones that it it it would render you
render you useless so you have to
maintain a certain level of testosterone
and you can't drop it so they have the
categories for disabled people they
should have it for transgender because
it's so difficult
i i don't i don't even disagree with
that statement but my point is the
activists don't want the people pushing
this don't want that because they want
to be 100 fully recognized and
accommodated as women so they don't want
a separate category to them that's
transphobic they're like no we don't
want a separate category
i'm a woman i want to and plus
disability is different because
um what's it called
you're you was born that way do you
understand for example some people can
be born with um no no leg no arm do you
understand you was born that way
i'm just saying some people are born
with disabilities you understand but um
transgenders are not born like that so
they have a choice so what she's trying
to say we should have that lbg clue
the alphabet olympics because you've got
the ordinary olympics you've got the
disabled olympics so you should have the
alphabet olympics i think it's
just like a category no transgender no
because they've got a category for
disabled people they've got their own
olympics you don't see disabled people
in with the regular olympics they've got
their own mm-hmm so what they basically
need is like the yeah the the
lgbtqia
the lgb is not a problem
l's g's and b's can be in the main thing
that's a sexuality what you feel to
understand is that what we're saying is
that
let them go and do their own thing but
don't compete against
proper male men and women if that
offends you i don't care but proper men
and women don't compete against proper
male and women
when you're the opposite trying to
pretend you can compete against the men
good luck to you
i want to go and do your own go and have
your own alphabet olympics yeah that's
what they need to have their own
okay can we touch on our modern women
men i remember
yeah we can after after super chat so
we're gonna take a second and read some
super chats
so guys thank you so much for the
donations today all donations are going
towards blessings new camera he wants to
shoot in 8k right blessing
um okay so and also make sure you like
the video the like is the most important
metric that youtube uses to push out
content so make sure you like the video
a like is free okay
jb
jb fm 101
it
it when her real viewpoints come out and
she quickly changes the girl is
literally the definition of sheep babes
go think for yourself and then come back
auntie jenny i'm sorry we can't save her
matt butcher rapunzel i i figured you
out you're trolling us and you're
killing it girl there has to be an award
for this maury zubi is debating with a
person who has a room iq temp it's
pointless and ultimately has diminishing
returns i respect his patience though
justine pearl i love your channel just a
quick question that's off topic can you
tag your whole video in the clips when
you post to your page because it's hard
to find them
the whole streams reference to them
alistar horton your mind doesn't
your mind doesn't does designate your
gender your body does
hyad al mo
i can't pronounce that name i'm sorry
auntie is the goat love your work pearl
steven bruce jenner got a woman pregnant
and nine months later he's caitlyn
jenner does caitlyn jenner just caitlyn
jenner still pay child support wendell
covent
please watch the documentary what is a
woman maurice pearl please let the woman
know that they are currently working
hard to approve petty because they are
feeling that way and can't control it a
fifth avenue phil i thought woman was
derived from one womb man or a man with
a womb they just removed the beat am i
right from the sarah tribe signing off i
am not a pr
signing off i am a pearly fan too
ro row boot um hands up for my g zooby
and thanks for the preferred ladies
example of traditional values miss pearl
and auntie
um much appreciated and i shall
contribute more in the near future god
bless and never stop alberto do you
believe in objective objective truth
partly cr clown world
um why is the girl in the white pants so
passionate for this bs that is the
result of brainwashing from our current
society um francis young they are
calling women phobic because they don't
they are calling
less women l-e-s less less women lesbian
oh [ __ ]
okay i was like this is making more
sense they're calling lesbian women
phobic because they don't want to do the
deed since they have a willy is that
okay with you gus can locks please
define misogyny um matt butcher
frustrating as f but rapunzel is good
for many men
for many to here to get out of their
manipulated brainwashing bubble if a
cult leader says
join or you will hurt my feelings what
would you do big breezy the nigerian
girl who is on castillo's show is
deluded foolishness is all on all
digital platforms brub oh
what castillo cause that were you on it
yeah it was oh shut up
wait which one
the dayton one oh my god that's so funny
we had the whole panel on the other day
yeah yeah the one girl's coming back
tomorrow that's funny i didn't even know
that um
okay maul i wonder if i can sneak into
an nba team as a seven foot two wilt
chamberlain and demand to be paid in
spite of my defensive liabilities as a
six foot one buck 80 dude um cobin
colin abney myron gaines is in the uk
this week andrew got to love when people
think someone is in the right to play
victim to circumstances they themselves
have chosen
it's ridiculous that people are
questioning their own gender why do we
need to come why do we need any
complicated definition why do we have to
change the definition with feelings make
it simple look at what mother nature
gave you as underwear um other worldly
oddities tv
how one feels doesn't matter i could
feel that the sky is green but it
doesn't make it so feelings don't equate
to facts matt butcher glad to see auntie
you know we are privileged as a society
when this is a problem live as you want
but if you expect to force others to
play along with it you are crossing the
line total hypocrites doug mpa
black women are the most combative and
hard-headed yet the most inclusive a
danger dangerous combination girl with
the long locks is a perfect example of
this tim neroth a grown man is a grown
adult a woman is a grown adult if you're
not then that
if you're not then you're just a boy or
a girl that hasn't learned how to be
mature as a man or a woman adult medic
91b ask what it is to be a man and see
how easy it is to answer that question
beanbag yozubi saw your first tim cast
in real life and that show was lit and
now you're on pearl's show let's go
um doug mpa pearl zubi auntie jess what
a show let's go gus women lose 80 of
their eggs by 30 90 to 95 by 35 if women
knew this how early would you they
changed the age of when they wanted to
get married and have kids shane karas
what is zoo bee short for just kidding
zooby
tell pearl to check out the
mysis caccus
mesi's caucus
what's that what's that it's a
segment of the libertarian party in the
us oh i don't even know that very
specific oh okay marriage marriage
causes divorce modern three or fours are
masculine as they earn a lot of money
have options and divorce laws favor them
my ruthless masculine ex-wife took 70 on
divorce okay guys thank you for the
super chats
so
um
okay did you say you had something to
say about modern women or what modern
women masculine
no she would just want to talk about it
but i do i do
i do want to go back to something that
you did say earlier about being
religious and growing up in the church
i've grown up in the church even before
i was born and i've heard everything
from the front of the bible to the back
of the bible and i believe the same as
you probably growing up and i don't
think it's closed-minded to have a truth
because if you if you correct me if i'm
wrong if you stand for everything you'll
fall for nothing or is that how is it
flip-flopped yeah
no stand for something or you fall for
everything is that how it's something
it's just if you essentially are like oh
free will for everything um essentially
you don't have
anything to stand on and
i i have people who are in the front of
the lgbtq plus whatever community to the
back of it and
i don't think it's closed-minded to have
an opinion you can be open-minded you
can hear them listen to them but you
don't have to essentially take in their
truth you can still believe what you
want to believe and stand on what you
want to believe and still treat them
respect them as humans but you don't
have to take it like okay you said that
that's your truth you said that that's
you i have to believe that as well no
you can still have your own beliefs and
they can still have their own beliefs
and everybody can still coexist and live
but the thing is that we were saying
well just
the topic is that
it feels like they're
pushing it on us it's the same as
someone was trying to shove a religion
down everybody so i was like no i said
you have to follow this you have to do
this it's essentially like that i say
i'm this if you do not say that i am
this you're getting fired your kids are
getting taken away there's so much much
more repercussion that comes with it
just because
you say
their identity wrong
how many people have gotten your name
wrong in life
yeah
that's
essentially that's black
yeah essentially that's what you
identify as is your name it's part of
you and if someone gets it wrong you're
like
how dare you
get him police officer it's it's kind of
crazy to think of it like that
because what i wanted to say was earlier
when i was saying
about if you had a child
and
your child decided they want to change
gender while they're at school
if everybody had your mindset
and things moving forward
how would you feel if your child got
taken away from you if you wouldn't let
you go to school wearing a dress
because with that mindset they will say
that you don't understand you're
listening and you're abusing that child
because you won't let that child be what
he wants to be and that's how far you
know
that's where it's going mm-hmm it's
already happening it's i have a problem
with that i'm not going to lie because i
do think as much as we want to
accommodate how they feel and understand
them we don't want to we can't be
punishing people because it's going to
take a long time to understand even i'm
yet still understanding things like me i
just all i want to do is listen that's
all i wanted i believe in equality for
everybody like you saying about standing
for
standing for something or you fall for
anything that is what i stand for
equality equality is not about just my
equality it's not just because i'm a
woman it's not just because i'm
privileged and i'm amongst the majority
it's about even when they're minorities
i want to hear you out because it's not
popular to hear you out but let me try
and understand it so maybe we can get to
a stage where
you know what maybe we actually fully
understand this so that's all it is for
me so a transgender woman is the same as
you you wouldn't have a transgender
woman come in and say i'm the same as
you i want all the rights as you
i'm just the same as you you'll be happy
about that
on another part what if
all these officials that we have in
office right now that are women making
um
essentially
the laws for the majority of women what
if a man transgender woman now comes in
and makes these laws
and women say men can't speak on these
things men can talk on these things but
now you have a transgender woman which
is originally a man coming and talking
is that is that okay and i
i would like everybody to answer it if
they can would that be the same thing or
would that be different
i'm not sure i totally understand the
questions
so just
essentially if a man if a woman made a
law and like okay women can talk about
the things for women but we say men
can't talk about
things for women because they're not
women but a transgender
woman comes into whatever space it is
are they allowed to speak on women's
issues
my answer to that one's easy i think
everybody is allowed to speak and have
an opinion on everything
but
what i mean what i think just means is
right then say there was
a club that you belong to a high-class
club
but
exclusively for women it's a secret
society just for women
don't allow no men in
and the transgender person comes hey but
i'm a woman now so i'm gonna i've come
to join
and they have a beard and testicles but
they identify as a woman
guys you can't change my mind in there
like i i respect without trying to
change
your mind yeah i respect how you feel
and i understand it because like i said
that's what i grew up around like my mom
would be like that is not a man
what i'm genuinely curious about what
i'm genuinely curious about is what was
the argument that made you change your
mind
because you're saying you all you used
to believe what we were saying yeah did
christianity what was that what was the
argument that changed your mind
probably seeing how many people were
hurt by the things i used to say
yeah definitely because we're humans and
feelings does matter like how can you
tell somebody do you think feelings
matter more than the truth
i think there's got to be a balance we
need to try and understand something you
can't say something is the truth when
we've not really tried to understand it
do you think it's interesting that in i
mean i've watched the whole i don't know
if you've seen the what is a woman
documentary but he goes and speaks to
people who are considered experts in
this whole field none of them will
answer the basic question right they
don't provide any actual arguments right
does is that not is that not telling
that there's not they won't even say
what a woman is they saw the clip didn't
make it right
they don't know who a woman is and
they're qualified they're professionals
they're professionals you can't just say
things and just say it but but if we but
if we're everybody's truth is so
different that's my point
if 99 of people the majority is not
always correct okay but if 99 of people
accept something and say okay this is
what it is and it's been this way all
throughout history and it's this way
throughout the entire animal kingdom
then for someone to come along and to
change that
you need a bulletproof
argument that is based on logic and
rationality
not on
random subjective feelings like that's
not that's not an argument saying saying
i heard it saying i feel is a subject it
is a valid feeling
if someone is hurt like emotionally like
someone so they're cutting themselves
and crying every
you're in control of how you feel if if
someone on the show wants to you know
say mean things to me i'm i'm in control
of how i react to it like like i was in
shortage the other day some girl called
me a slack i didn't even know what that
meant i knew i was being insulted
and then she like knocks the mic out of
my hand and was like you know getting
all up in arms and like i i could you
know be hurt by that but i'm not gonna
be hurt like i'm in control of my
emotions and it's the same thing like if
a grown adult someone misgenders you
you're in control of how you react and
how you feel yeah yeah again i i'm very
i'm very very consistent with this thing
so i'm a christian right i believe in
god i believe jesus christ is the son of
god and you know
i don't i'm allowed to believe
what i believe
if i were going around
and i were trying to force every single
person into everyone in the world to
believe
exactly what i believe and say the same
things and incantations that i said
that's the thing i i'm not understanding
you've got people making laws saying
that you are not you can be banned from
social media for quote unquote
misgendering or dead naming someone it's
this is not we're not talking about why
why are you talking about the desire
to i mean
i don't understand the desire
i'm going to refer to a man as a he this
is how the language works i'm not going
to
talk to him just don't talk like
literally ignore him focus on what you
know and what you want to know why why
are you talking about it i don't get it
we're in this room okay we're in this
room okay if i'm talking about i want to
refer to something pearl says i'll say
oh she said right this is this is
grammar this is how how the language
works yeah right this is how it works in
fact if i'm talking to you one on one i
don't use those pronouns because i'll
just call you you yeah right it's only
when you're in a group conversation
all right
i'm happy not that hard i don't
understand but it's not that simple
i could come and say look i think look
i'm offended by blasphemy
i don't like people using god's name in
vain i don't like people saying nasty
things about jesus i don't like my
religion and other religions being
insulted right
would it be reasonable for me would it
be progressive of me to try to create
laws
that make it illegal or which get you
de-platformed from instagram or twitter
or youtube or social media for saying
something that goes against my religious
beliefs no i would be considered hyper
in tal that would be me being
unreasonable that would be me being the
one who's not tolerant that would be me
being the one who's being it's not the
other people i i'm i'm a grown adult i'm
a grown man i'm not going to lie to you
it doesn't actually affect any part of
my life i think it's because you're so
hyper anti yet oh my gosh
i don't i don't think
just wait
i really don't think you understand how
deep this whole thing has gone i think
you're thinking this is just
hypotheticals i mean i had a woman at
work and i remember basically on her
details
it basically said on man's details but i
heard it on the phone and it was a woman
and i was like
wait is this the client like is should i
do some dbs check but the thing is all i
thought in that situation is
well
this could be a woman that's
transgendered and that's okay it's not a
big deal
let me ask you a couple very simple
questions okay some couple simple
questions would you be comfortable with
me being in your changing room
probably not why
well because you're a man and i don't
want to be seen what if i identify as a
woman
still looking like that yeah but you
look like a man if you probably look
like a woman i wouldn't even know what
if i still what if i still had a penis
and testicles well that's the whole
point of transgender because you don't
you don't you don't know no no no no
it's not no it's not no it's not no it's
not yeah well i guess in that in that
instance you should definitely transform
first before you can be using facilities
but by because it's confusing let's be
honest it's confusing
if a man walks into a woman's changing
room i'm going to be whoa why isn't he's
in the wrong changing room so that i'm
going to be honest about but it's not
saying that you can feel however you
want to feel we're not discussing people
no one has said that people are not
allowed to feel how they feel it's not
it's not an argument yeah but when it
comes to real life
scenarios like that then yeah of course
there should be rules that okay until
you look like that sex then you can use
their facilities you can't just walk in
there because you're going to scare
people okay just ask you something um
you were saying that you were raised in
a religious background a religious
household
were you like class yourself as a
christian
are you just religious
no did you
yeah yeah i was very very religious did
you think this i would never know what
i'm trying to say is that did you find
it
stifling
is it hard work because it sounds like
to me
it sounds like you're really religious
and that you went out there and you just
and then somebody got hurt and then it's
like you know what
if he said it after what he said if he
after the declaration that he made just
now speaking of a religious person
compared to you
i would say that your faith was weak and
they got you while you was open i just
think you have no right to say that
because you don't know me and you i'm
going by what you said
excuse me excuse me excuse me i'm going
by what you said number one you said you
grew up in a religious
household then you said that you used to
go and talk down to all the gay people
and that you offended somebody and then
you said that you went to china and that
they didn't have religion they was doing
this or this and it was all free i could
only go by what you said yeah but all
i'm trying to say is
back then i was very strong like i was
to the extent that i was like if i let
you do anything i'm gonna go to hell but
the point is i got to a stage where i
stopped thinking about religion and god
and i thought about what do i think
about it i grew up in a christian home
because i had no other choice that's all
i was taught so imagine actually if i
was if i grew up in a home where there
was no religion forced on me what would
i have grown up as so
that's just what confused as you are now
no no see what i mean that's the point
you cut you can have your own belief but
not put down other people's belief
you're saying that i was confused i can
say you're confused no because that's
not what you're saying but what you're
saying him as a christian now if he met
somebody and there was gay he wouldn't
come down you're going to hell you're
going to know you wouldn't say that
because as a christian you supposed to
respect everybody you might not agree
with their religion you might not agree
because me i can say that i'm a
christian my best friend's gay
because him being gay has nothing to do
with him being my friend
and i wouldn't turn around and say to
him oh you shouldn't be gay you
shouldn't do this you shouldn't say that
aggressive so it was just i'm going to
say how i expect you said that you was
with him yeah but you're saying like in
a very aggressive manner like i was just
going around telling you because you're
going to help that is what you say it
was just a conversation oh yeah but
my pastor was um about it and i don't
want you to set it up you said you're
backtracking now you're backtracking you
want me to explain it no exactly
she is going off of how you acted out
what you just said the word you just
said that is what she has to go off of
so if she is saying that you said it
like this she's going off she's going
off of what you and so now you're trying
to backtrack because you don't like the
way it makes you look but you you said
it i wasn't aggressive yeah right right
now but i'm saying i'm saying she's
auntie drew a conclusion based on the
words that came out of your mouth and
when she drew this conclusion based on
what you said now now you're backtracked
i just thought it was quite rude to
really say that my religion and my uh my
faith was weak because that's your
question how can you just no you didn't
know me when you go back to it i asked
you i said was your religion weak no you
didn't think you said that means your
faith is weak and that's the problem you
are watching again and you'll be
surprised at how you come across and
what you've said you said your faith was
weak and you didn't do that he said yeah
he went around and he was talking down
to people and saying you're going to go
to hell yeah because you're gay we'll
clip it out we'll clip it later we'll
clip it
yeah but you definitely said that my
fake fate was weak that's why i thought
it was really good
what could i believe your faith was peak
if you said did you believe your faith
was weak that's your offspring now watch
this again
you're watching we'll watch it yeah no
no you she she said a word you got
triggered and then you and then you then
you and then you see we see
okay why are you over talk you overtalk
everybody here even auntie's like twice
your age that's so rude like why are you
over talking to everyone
thank you
okay i think i should leave now
because i'm i'm gonna be no why why
because when this is getting something
like we could actually have a
conversation without people being
inspired but you're gonna hear what i
was saying
so
when you're in a panel like this you
guys have a podcast it may not be as
many people as this but when you're in a
setting like this you have to say what
you think
state your thing have other people
respond to it and i'm not i don't want
this to feel like i'm attacking you or
anything but it's just in the space that
you're in you have people
talking but when you're over talking
someone that's showing that you don't
really care what they have to say you
want to get your point across no matter
what it is that anybody else has to say
so that's just podcast etiquette it's
just to talk let somebody else respond
wait till they take a break and then
respond
if you have something else to rebuttal
from what they just that's not the
problem the problem is she said my faith
was weak and i responded to that because
that's insulting there's no need to be
insulting on a podcast
your face was weak or did i ask you your
face this week or did i say i think
maybe your your faith was weak which one
did i say did i tell you
you didn't ask me that's that's it you
didn't ask me you literally made a
statement based off of what you said
she was drawing she was drawing a
conclusion based off of i'm sorry that i
used your words to offend you
that's not really anything it's just an
opinion i don't i don't believe offense
was i don't think offense or insult was
the goal i don't think i don't think
that was i as far as i'm concerned i've
never been on there and insulted anybody
because that's not the way i am
okay
we're talking about understanding
we are all ultimately trying to
understand each other here like that
we're asking these questions and we're
we're genuinely trying to understand
your position yeah right i'm not here
trying to i've haven't insulted at all
i'm genuinely trying to i don't feel
insulted by anything you've said and i i
literally stated it i didn't appreciate
that she's saying my faith was weak you
didn't know me so that's all i had to
say yeah it's just an opinion
okay well i'm gonna react to the next
clip
um blessing
let's not do this one do the um the next
one after this
just because we kind of moved from the
trans
um
no do the do the
yeah do
that one top g yeah so um
so since i kind of wanted to combine um
you know the the trans issue with or
modern women so i decided to bring i i
feel like
andrew tate right now is like the
forefront front of the red pill so let's
let's watch
um
shout out andrew we miss you on youtube
i had influence of control over it what
do you mean
the photographer can get the angles here
no no no no not doing any real work but
just like taking all the money
if my chick said i wanna do only fans
i'm like all right then cool go do it
how much you made 10 grand or give me
eight alright cool why would what woman
is gonna give you eight grand you're my
woman you're doing only fans you're
selling my product the [ __ ] your product
yes
next question
i don't know if you're being serious i'm
totally serious how would i let my chick
the only thing to keep all the money
that's disrespectful what woman is ever
going to give you that then she brought
your only fans duh
what would you do if i wanted to start
an only fans i don't think there's
anything intrinsically wrong with women
doing only things
as long as i had influence and control
over it what do you mean doing the
photographer to get the angles here no
no no no not doing any real work but
just like taking all the money
if my chick said i wanna do only fans
i'm like alright then cool go do it how
much you made 10 grand or give me eight
all right cool why would what woman is
going to give you eight grand you're my
woman
pause it yeah
okay um so the reason i brought up this
clip um is because i i think that
sometimes like the
the math like women becoming more
masculine and men becoming more feminine
kind of stems from our lack of being
able to define either
and you know now we have andrew tate um
just tell me what you think of the clip
you can start
what's the question
yeah yeah what do you what's your
reaction um
i i i think everything that this guy
says has so much truth behind it to be
honest and um
yeah i
i personally agree
um i wouldn't be
myself ever do only fans i don't think
my boyfriend would particularly like
that
but if that was the case
um i think we would have a setup like
that quite honestly that he would take
the majority of the money because he has
responsibility of me
and he takes care of me
um but only fans wouldn't come into it
but i could definitely relate with other
things where he has responsibility of me
there is a level of authority that comes
with that
um and for me being a woman it's it's um
it's a really good place to be but just
a lot of
these days a lot of people don't agree
with that as you know yeah bro marry her
um
[Music]
my view yeah is your girl doing only
oh
i would not date a girl doing only fans
i wouldn't even
remotely consider it
not in the slightest um but he's would
you say would you say some instagram
pages are only fans for free
yeah the whole only fancy thing it's
freaking weird man like it i have i have
some feelings on that it's not something
i've really ever talked about but um
yeah it's uh
it's not for me um but i think he's he's
absolutely got a point in that if that
is what
she
wants to be doing and putting out there
then
you know the man should should have a
say in that in terms of the numbers you
know eighty percent i don't i don't know
about the numbers but um you know
there's got to be a there's got to be a
say in there but i don't think i i don't
look people can do what they want some
people won't like me saying that bro if
you're if you're a guy i don't think you
should be
encouraging your girl to
do only fans personally but look people
can do their weird she's strong and
independent
i think it's funny when women even say
that because if a guy says that he's
strong and independent it sounds so
ridiculous it's just like a strong
independent man
okay dude
yeah it's it's a strange thing you know
if i'm about people just being about it
if you have to keep like saying that
you're something then
it actually reeks of insecurity to me
like i don't walk around talking about
i'm a strong man i'm an independent i'm
smart it's just like dude just just be
you just be about it you know just just
be it people can see it if you are
[Music]
i've come to realize actually seeing a
lot of andrew tate recently i actually
agree with a lot of what he says
bring back the top jew right
how did they do
you yeah for freedom of speech
everyone's gonna always have opinions
aren't they they might agree or disagree
but i found myself agreeing with a lot
of things he said and that is probably
one of them
perhaps not 80 that's quite a wild
figure
but
as pearl touched on which i can resonate
with
me personally my actual instagram could
be considered probably is considered
quite close to only fans it makes uh i
have a reasonable number of followers i
can make money off it
i think i'd be quite lucky to have a man
who would not only tolerate that but
encourage it so actually having him say
that would be something i'd be
open to because i think it's very hard
to come across a male who would actually
encourage it and accept it let alone
monetize from it so
yeah i i agree with him wholeheartedly
perhaps again 90 percent
negotiation maybe maybe 70. i'm putting
in the most of the work here and got my
foot on my head and god knows what he's
not doing that but if he's taking
pictures and the like and he's my man
and he's going to say he's my man and
we're going to be out in public together
and he's got a sets down there with me
knowing that men are paying to see
things that he doesn't pay to see
i can see why he wanted me on your feet
100
i can't disagree with her at all
okay what do you think
um i wouldn't do only fans
i don't encourage women to do it i just
think
the idea of putting a price on your body
i think it demeans women
further
and i definitely don't agree with what
you say in because i think what andrew
tate is suggesting that he owns the
woman
if you don't want your woman to do only
fans don't be with her simple if you're
going to be with a woman that does only
fans that is her hustle it's like you
may be having something that's not
agreeable as a career maybe you're a
trapper right and then your woman coming
into your business and saying well it's
quite embarrassing being with a trapper
you know because i i work in the 9 to 5
legal sector so you know what i want
some i want a cup
i feel like that's unacceptable why
would i be able to do that so why can
you come into my hustle and you want a
cup because you're a man
i have a question when when you get
married or do you want to get married
yeah do you will you give him control of
the
money no
we could share the money so it could be
right but like at the end of the day
someone's got to make a financial
decision like like if one person wants
to buy a house and one person doesn't
someone has to have the final say
see that's i i've never understood that
concept i don't understand why there
needs to be
one like this idea of having a one alpha
man in a relationship i can't understand
it why can't we both be alpha because
why can't we buy
because okay if you're if you're gonna
run a company like someone has to lead
yeah if you have more experience in that
field say you you dealt with property
before and you know what you know
everything about this then darling take
it but imagine i have gone in like done
years of like experience and i've gone
to school learning about properties and
then you want to come to me and say
because i'm a man i feel like i should
miss a decision i'd be like hell no
because at the end of the day it's about
expedition i don't know any women that
are good with money
i don't know anything
well when it comes to saving women are a
lot better than me no they no they're
not we
we spend more even though we make less
we own some we own 70 of consumer debt i
mean i grew up in a household where um
it's the opposite my mom has a lot of
assets more than my dad so i i've seen
it work where it's like a woman can
create assets she can save a lot of
money and invest and grow and build so i
don't that's why i've never understood
it because i've seen a woman do it so i
guess that's what shaped my belief okay
okay what do you think i don't agree
with that statement um because i feel
like um it's coming off controlling
why am i entitled to give my man
what i've worked for that does not make
sense to me whatsoever so
in that sense yeah no that's controlling
it's because it's because of the nature
of the work then don't date someone
that's that that's a reference i would
agree with you
if you want a partner
you can find um
ladies everywhere do you understand so
yeah that's yeah i i i agree man i don't
i don't think dudes should be
you know
dating girls doing that not seriously
anyway but but
people can have their
yeah well that's that's what he is
what do you say though like and if i
mean because that and that clip they're
dating but if you're married like i feel
like someone has to control the money
look at you
sorry sorry to cut you off you can't
have a democracy with only two people
you're going to have a decision maker
and it doesn't mean on every single
issue the decision maker is the same in
in most traditional
families which by the way we still need
to remember is like probably 80 plus of
marriages around the world um the man
typically has the final say on certain
things and the woman typically has the
final say on certain things that's just
how
it is that's actually what human beings
tend to default to of course everyone's
an individual there's all sorts of
exceptions and personal circumstances
and so on but that's typically that
that's typically how it goes but you
can't if you've only got two people it
doesn't even matter if it's not a
marriage if you've only got two people
and a decision needs to be made someone
ultimately you can negotiate and you
should negotiate and the other person
should always have a say but ultimately
one person is going to have to
make a decision
let's go
you can flip a coin i mean
you could do it but yeah someone someone
has to have the authority and i think
the the truth is that women do not
respect
men who do not have a level of authority
this this is the truth a man who will
not lead i'm sure you don't like it if
you go out on a date with a guy and he's
like oh should we go i don't know but
where do you where do you want to go
where
it's lame and it's and that's not
something that's reciprocated like as a
man
if a woman is indecisive or what like
that's not a turn off right that's just
yeah she's she's a woman i'm i'm
supposed to be the one
if i'm asking a girl out on a day i'm
not i i'll pick the restaurant cool i'll
i'll sort the stuff out that's just
that's just how it is
it's biologically rooted
and yes there can be exceptions but
you know if
there's there's always exceptions right
i wouldn't expect a man to take a cut of
my money if i was working in a normal
industry no no way i'd be like how dare
you take my money but i think in that
specific industry where you're literally
why because he's allowing you to do it i
feel like unfortunately yes if you're
married i want the dude to make all the
financial decisions
i don't i see the way women spend and i
would say i'm not even bad for a girl
but like i just yeah i feel like dude
should control money can i just say my
piece now yeah go ahead and there's a
stuck in the corner well i think they
should stop listening to
how he says things and listen to what he
says
because i think he he says a lot of good
things
but i just think it's how he says it
just to hype people up
and i think that if he
wanted to be all nice about it that most
a lot of people would agree with him but
it's the way he says it and i don't know
who that woman is anyway but for
instance if it was i looked at
was it the only fans
i was checked out what it was
and then they realized that no because
they do cooking on there
and they do bodybuilding on there
you know they've got women that look
quite respectable that do cooking
programs
but
because she said it and because he said
it everybody automatically thinks too
you know so as far as i'm concerned if
you're if it was any other job
and say that they were married and
people say oh no but they're not married
if you're in the long-term relationship
and you're living together you're
heading towards that way somebody's got
to be the decision maker and
it's always our money until it's the
women's money
you know what's yours is ours and what's
mine is mine
you know because
if you're married in your relationship
surely
all the money would go into a pot
rather than
oh i'm not gonna give him this because
it's how much
my son's grandparents
married couple they're married they were
together until they one died and the
other one died until they died and
i remember she always worked and handed
over her money to her husband
she works handed over her money to her
husband
and he always
well he said oh they had five children
so the children's whatever they grown up
kids
that was the housekeeping so the parents
give the mother whatever the children
give the mother whatever they have to
give her but they could understand why
is it that
she has to give all of her wages to her
husband
and they thought was really strange
and then
one day he just said right we're going
and he's built this fantastic house in
st lucia on the top of this hill
fan no way she would have done that and
she spent the money
and i think if that was me
and i was whether it's only fans or
whatever
i'd quite happily hand over the money
and
give me my housekeeping i let it work
you do whatever you got to do with it
because once i'm with you i should if i
trust in you of my body why can't i
trust you with my money my money not
until i finish talking though
so as far as i'm concerned it doesn't
matter because i ain't finished oh okay
right
because as far as i'm concerned
my body is more valuable to me than
money
i don't understand why women
they will share their bodies but they
don't want to share their money
so as far as i'm concerned she's out
there sharing her body to if we go by
that only fans whatever's on there my
view was hanging in a minute she's out
there sharing her whole body to the
whole world how many people but she
won't share the money with the man
and as far as i'm concerned if he's the
man and i'm like you when it comes to
religion and he's the head let him deal
with the money and when people are going
to be offended by he said he's allowing
him to do that well that's his wife he's
the head he's in charge he's allowing
her to do that so as far as i'm
concerned
if you're both working in your
partnership the money's supposed to go
into the house together i wouldn't even
say like oh eight grand i'll give him
all of it
i'd give him every single penny and as
far as i'm concerned i'm trusting you
with my body i want to trash money is
nothing compared to my body
you know and that that's my point of
view why is it so easy just to give away
your body rather than give away the
money and it's sometimes like when
you're like when it's the same analogy
really as when like you're young and
like i don't know five ten and your
grandma will give you i don't know 100
pounds or something for christmas and
your mom and dad take it from you and
say okay we're going to take this i'm
going to put this in a
bank account for you or whatever we'll
keep it for you when you need it
and then it's that
whole thing of safety again the money's
safe it's gone it's out of like the
child's hands
and personally as a woman like i
sometimes look at the way that i spend
and it is
i wouldn't want to say it's like
childish like i'm not buying junk and
stuff i don't need it's things that i
feel that i need but it would sometimes
be better off
in someone else's hands than mine but i
could not believe that's a bit different
though because with a child they're
irresponsible do you understand yeah but
i can be irresponsible sometimes
they might have to work on you you need
to work on that do you understand and be
that independent woman
yeah but don't women but women are by
and large irresponsible with money
like the majority of women what are
irresponsible yeah if you look at it
for example for example a lot of people
like there's a lot of girls here who
have got
nice nail varnish on gel nails acrylic
nails that's something where i wish i
could kind of cut back on a little bit
i've been having these since i was 16
the same color the same everything
the amount of
money that this costs you girls know
that the nail bars are going up every
single year every six months there's
another five pound climb another 10
pound climb
and it's literally thousands of pounds
that i am spending
a year on just
this is just for the nails for getting
the hair the makeup everything else
and
sometimes i i do feel that it would be
safer that if i was putting that money
where someone's to say look i'm going to
take that off you let me take
responsibility of it it's gonna be okay
just trust me
then maybe i'd have a bit more like
it would be like a good thing for me but
being left to my own devices i'm gonna
go and continue to have nails now that's
not saying that i don't agree that all
women should have nail varnish nails i
think it's really important
but you see there's that like 50 50
there that actually if i was with
someone who you know
cares loves me like for example my
boyfriend he brought me a voucher and it
was left behind at the
behind the nail salon
counter whatever
and it was the third time that i went in
there it was a hundred pounds
and he said oh you've got 10 pounds left
like the guy that owns the place and i
just saw my gosh and i didn't want to
tell my boyfriend i've already spent the
voucher it doesn't mean i'm going to get
the nails done every week
but it was in the right timings at two
to three weeks
but the money was gone and it was so
quick
and i could literally see it being
written each time
and even like with like building this
channel like i feel like
i've been able to do it because my dad
and my brothers helped me with the money
i don't think i could do it on my own
like at all especially crazy i was in
the morning you see me cry every
once in a while you have to do the
account can i ever women spend more time
buying what they need rather than buying
what they want like men do they save a
lot more money
yeah i would never get my nails done
because i think to myself when you work
it out i could buy an apartment
yeah that's yeah i grew up in an african
household and the women are better with
money so i guess you guys your your
experience are different
but like a lot of moms that i know that
are black
what they can save they are great with
mine and i'm going to agree with you
because my mom she's gone in do you
understand and when my dad was alive
them two
my mom used to save more do you
understand there were times when my dad
would borrow mum from
borrowing money from my mom do you
understand so
she was more mindset with money
so
that statement i'm a bit
with it
i don't
i don't think it's a
there are some things that i think are
heavily
have a lean towards one sex or the other
um
saving money i don't
necessarily think is is one of them i
think i think that's just like a
personality type and an individual thing
yeah there's people who there's people
who are just bad with money yeah
there's dudes who go out and they gamble
and they spend and they buy trainers
they just buy they buy nonsense and
there's women who go out and blow their
money on nonsense and you know i
i don't think it's that gendered but i
think i think perhaps a more important
point is that if you have got that
person you've got uh
you know your wife your husband whatever
it's supposed to be a partnership right
it's it's supposed to be a partnership
and different individuals can work out
how that works if it's like okay look
babe you're really good with money i'm
kind of reckless with spending it you
handle the saving or investing or
whatever or it could be you know what
i'm the one who knows how to invest and
save and whatever like i'll handle the
majority of that
as long as it works as a unit and you
know i think and i understand people
wanting to be
independent independent independent but
i think that mindset can be
quite dangerous for relationships when
you're not willing to entrust
the other person it's a partnership
right you can entrust that person and
say you know what you're good at
handling that you handle this i'm good
at handling this i've got this you don't
need to worry about it you don't need to
be working in isolation all the time i
think it's good for every adult male
female whatever i think it's good for
every adult to be competent to have
general competencies so that if you're
single or something goes wrong or
whatever you're not totally you're not
you're not useless right i think
everybody should know how to cook basic
food
right i don't think it's just you know a
woman should know how to cook a mansion
i think if you are a grown man and
you're 35 years old and you don't know
how to boil rice or cook a basic meal
i'm like bro like come on man yeah right
you should know how to load load
you know how to load load the washing
you should know how to do some some
basic tasks everyone should know how to
make money right at least on a basic
level some people are going to be better
at it than others but you should have a
skill you should have a couple
monetizable skills
that okay even if you're not
right like i'm not married yet but when
i am like my wife is absolutely not
going to have to work right not a paid
job per se right she's going to be doing
some type of work she can have a typical
job if she wants to she won't have to
um
but i would like to marry someone who i
know is competent so that god forbid
something happens to me or whatever like
my kids are not gonna starve and be
destitute
um
but yeah i just think it's about finding
that
finding that balance and that
those complementary aspects and i think
that when people partner up and and do
that well
then the whole the whole thing just
functions and it's good and you can just
trust the other person i agree and then
you're not worried about this this is my
money that's your money and then it gets
kind of weird and you're keeping score
right i think keeping scores i think we
live in an age now where men don't want
to accept that women are competent and
because back in the days it worked you
go to work i cook i clean i take care of
the kids but now women are working so
don't come home and tell me to cook and
clean because we've just come from the
same [ __ ] well what i think i think i
think you'll you'll just the truth is
you'll have to find uh
you know
a man who
is who who accepts that right but the
the problem is the type of man who will
fully accept what you just said there
i imagine is not the type of man you'd
be attracted to mm-hmm
you see what i mean so i think i think
that's what there's that's one of the
conflicts which is like there's a lot of
bums that are okay they're totally fine
yeah like there's a they like it yeah
you can you could date a bum
but that's the
that's the message we keep passing on to
men that as soon as you're alpha and
you're confident you have to see a woman
as less than you or you have no idea
subordinate no that's that's the message
we keep passing on you can be strong
okay okay i need you i need you i need
you i'm just gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna
cut you yeah who who says that no you
said the passive message we're passing
on who says that no but saying things
like well no
like let me say answer your question so
he literally just said i imagine a man
that's okay with that you're not going
to be attracted to right because because
he's not going to be in his masculine
energy
a masculine man
would not
is is not going to be drawn
to that
it's not about me i'm attracted to you
well yeah i'm just i'm saying no you can
you can be how you want i'm not i'm not
telling you what to do or how to behave
or whatever i'm just telling you real
talk as a man
um
you know you can you can have a certain
attitude or belief system or whatever
i'm just saying
a guy who like there there are guys who
would just be like yeah cool like you
know either that whatever but the type
those type of guys tend to be more
you know weak frame not so much in their
masculine energy not particularly
ambitious and so on like why would why
would a guy that makes a lot of money go
to his girl for financial decisions yeah
like like why why would he do that when
he could just not when there's a million
she has a lot of money as well but again
like but your money doesn't matter to a
guy it's like nothing it's like it's
like like imagine when a guy tells us oh
i have a cool shoe collection you're
like cool but you don't really care it's
the same thing and so you can come in
and like say oh i have money too he says
okay don't care
so it's like and then you know but then
why would you wait but i'm saying i'm
saying no women can we care about money
let's not cap women come on like you're
not you're not trying to date a bomb
you know like but but a guy will
like a guy will see a girl at tesco and
say
if she's hot enough cool yeah yes and
similarly she could be the freaking ceo
of a company but if she's not hot and
as nice
then you're not interested are you are
you lining up to date oprah no
no she's got not even lining up today
excuse me oprah is beautiful you know
the truth is and look and we all know
this men and women are not attracted to
the identical same things yeah we know
this and there's no amount of social
engineering that is going to
that that's going to just change that
right i'm sure look every short guy
would love to
somehow manipulate society and culture
and biology to make women more attracted
to
very short guys right but it's just it's
not reality so if you're a short dude
you just have to accept look this is my
i can't change this right but there's
lots of other things that i can do
there's ways that i can improve myself
and compensate and still be an
attractive and and confident and
competent man but you just have to
accept that given reality as a male
there are certain things that men are
generally attracted to in women and some
people may not like that it may trigger
them right
here's one that you can't change age
that's not that's not changeable right
but so if a man says that a man if a man
if a woman says that she prefers taller
guys which literally every woman does
no one takes offense to that if a man
says if a guy is 35 and he's like yeah i
prefer dating younger women
oh my god right he's suddenly some
despite the fact that every man all
throughout history whatever
go ahead yeah can i just say something
sorry
finish what you were saying and then i
can i've pretty much made my point so go
ahead okay
is sort of going off of the back of that
as well is that actually when you
are and this is only something that i've
come to like realize in the last
i'd say sort of six months that actually
being older like no matter how much i've
tried to run away from it tried to
change it looks wise all those things
would be like this is bad you know why
why can't i just be 26 again 25 again
all that is actually it's actually
really powerful being in that space and
feeling that way because that way i can
in a female way keep leveling up
keep you know keep on top of trying to
stay in shape trying to stay healthy
um keeping
my womanhood as much as i possibly can
you know i know you probably can't
imagine this right now because you're 26
but when you're 10 12 years older than
that it takes a lot of work
to
i don't know if to still feel
useful
to still feel youthful and useful in a
way to
um my partner
to blend into society because you
when you're when you're 26 you kind of
get a lot more on your plate
in your life than you do when you're 36.
as a woman as a woman they're not as a
guy but as a woman things completely
changed like when you were
22 i bet things were very different to
what they are
now at 26. there's all those jumps i
don't know if you you've had that
realization but it will help you to like
keep leveling up as a woman like guys
they focus on fitness and money and
whatever it may be to level themselves
up but
for me
you know yes it's exhausting
yes it costs money but it keeps me
healthier and in a better balance as a
woman within myself even though i might
be doing it more for my boyfriend it's
actually
rubbing off on me shouldn't that be a
human being thing because
i want to look good yeah i do but i
expect my mind to look good and this is
why i won't go for a sugar daddy i don't
care how much money you have i'm not
attracted to you a lot of women would
because like you said it's exciting
idris albert is beautiful come on no i'm
saying
who is your sugar daddy
that's not a sugar daddy
that is my whole husband what do you
mean
who's
i'm so sorry but how do you not know
he's probably better known in the uk as
well to be fair uh okay
yeah he's he's better known in the uk
i've heard a lot of americans
yeah he's known in the us but i think
he's better known i think he's better
known here
yeah i think he's better known here to
be fair we black people know what what
we know we think everyone else knows it
but you should know edith
please do you'd know him if you saw him
okay
but my point is i do think
like we keep thinking it's this idea we
keep passing this message that it's okay
for a man to just have money no it's not
go to the gym and work out all the money
ain't gonna say i don't think
i think that's a straw man i don't think
anyone is saying men just need to have
money yeah but that the point we were
just talking about the point is that
it's a factor it's a factor for men it's
it's um
women no no
for men yeah yeah my point is if you ask
a man
what five things are you looking for in
a woman money is almost never going to
come up job is almost never going to
come up qualifications are almost never
going to come up it's not true the other
way around
to be fair not nowadays because men be
having sugar mommies nowadays it's true
what maybe one for every 20 girls that
do i mean it's but it's happening like
have you seen how many men on only fans
now yeah but that's for gay men no
straight men
customers are we actually we actually we
actually did have an only fans guy on
the show that like his primary customers
no they're
no no but i'll tell you what it is
though he they don't make that much
money no he doesn't he doesn't make near
as much like it's not even the ones who
are the ones who are earning a lot their
audience is gaming yeah but the pro the
reason for that is because it's not a
market for women it's a market for men
pay for sex
that's just the way it is yeah exactly
so that's the only reason you think if
men were making a lot of money you think
they won't join only fans really no i've
never seen it i'm just
because of male sexuality is different
from female sexuality same reason that
male prostitutes
you know their audiences their clientele
are gay men like it's men who buy sex as
you as you said yeah it's men who buy
sex it's men who buy porn and so on and
so forth it's a very very small
percentage of women who are the market
for that and it's always been that way
across societies across countries across
cultures male sexuality is is different
from female sexuality and that's fine
that's good that's not a bad thing why
do you guys think that women are
becoming masculine nowadays because men
are becoming feminine
no honestly you know it's i put a lot of
blame on on men for a lot of the stuff
that you know even even men men complain
about mm-hmm right um really i feel like
it started with the women
look look
some of it does but men men have created
the certain conditions on a big level
right right okay look how many people
how many people are raised by how many
millions of people in western society
now
are raised by single mothers right but
why
oftentimes because men are not playing
their role mm-hmm that exists
that's that's a big thing but then
you've got an imbalance right you've got
both men and women are being raised
primarily
just by women and the masculine role is
missing and that manifests differently
for both
for for boys and girls as they grow into
as they grow into men and women and as a
woman it's
naturally
if if a man is not present there you've
now got to play both you've got to play
both roles so now you're done you what
no you don't
well i mean you're i was a single parent
that's that's this is a lie that the
women say this okay
what i mean is you you are
it's a it's a typically raising a child
is a two-person job
you have the father you have the mother
and in the absence of a father whether
that is through
death or through absence or through
whatever the reason
what i mean what i mean by play both
roles is you've got one person
doing a two-person mm-hmm
we pick who gets born so it's our own
fault like that's why i say it starts
with the women i don't know because and
like and on top of that like it's the
development of birth control i feel like
the development yeah but men made all of
that
those laws
you're right i would say if i was to put
it on men i would say it's because they
developed
men did all that meant men are the ones
who who made those laws even men's men
are the ones who came up with no fault
divorce men are the ones who come up so
you know i can't just
i know i know it's popular to kind of
put it all on
one gender
um and i think that you know there's
there there's both a fault but if i look
at it
ultimately you know men men have played
a massive role i'm not saying every
single man of course not right but men
in general have played a
a massive role in this oftentimes by not
stepping into
their proper masculine roles and leaving
it for
women to pick up the what do you mean
can you explain that more
what i mean is you know if i get a woman
pregnant right okay
and
i
can
step up and do what i'm supposed to do
morally
ethically
family socially cultural like i'm i'm
i'm supposed to step up into that right
and and i and i choose not to i choose
to
abandon
i choose to leave her to fend for
herself and deal with that or what maybe
maybe i'm sending a check every you know
a couple right then
that's that's my bad and by the way and
this is and this is happening to the
tune of millions
and i i agree with you but i'm sure
you're so familiar with the red pill you
know women women are the ones that leave
we live seventy to eighty percent of the
time ninety percent of college education
so so so like while while there are two
sides to it like we could talk about the
thirty percent like that wouldn't you
start with the seventy percent what
women are the ones i think we're talking
about two different situations right so
we're talking well you just said so the
male abandonment tends to happen at a
relatively early stage uh-huh right so
the child is born the child is not even
born yet and the dude disappears slips
out the picture and then and then you're
talking about there's actually a
relationship or a marriage and then the
woman
breaks away
from that yeah true both i i would say
women leave relationships more too and
in the first situation like we know when
we're ovulating so i just feel like if
we're in control of birth like that's on
us and a lot of times girls will like
try to make a guy that's not a husband
and do a husband and they'll try to like
get pregnant and keep the kid like and
so so it's like i'm not going to put
that on the men when you knew who he was
and i put it on both okay okay i put it
on both i'm not going to let men off the
hook here
right just like i don't i wouldn't let
women off the hook if someone was trying
to put this all on men i'd be like no no
you can't let women off the hook if also
someone's trying to put it all on
uh on a woman i'm like well you can't
let men off the hook right there's
millions and millions of men out there
who are not doing
what they're supposed to be doing
as a single parent
i think that
and i was saying that many invented the
pill
but somebody must have invented cyanides
or poison nobody
made them take it
right so just because somebody's making
something
that means that oh you can go ahead and
take it
and when it comes to single parents
it can understand you saying
i've only got one child
single parent one child
but when you get women having three four
five six seven children eight i think
there's some out there nine that was
still looking for dates sometimes by
nine different fathers can't put it all
on the men i'll say yeah the first one
yeah because
a lot of men
don't ask to be fathers
they don't ask to be fathers my son's
dad never asked to be a father actually
i was on the pill it was an accident i
actually discussed it with him and even
though he agreed that i have the child
i was
i knew that if i had to raise him on my
own i did because he never asked for him
and i don't believe in abortion
so as far as i'm concerned
single parent says no excuse
even if the father's not there there's
plenty of really good role models out
there male role models you know you've
got the grandfathers you've got the
uncles you've got the really good
friends
and then you should be able to do that
with a child without expecting anything
my son is 36 years old
i think in all his life i took 100 from
his dad
that's what he asked for 100 pound for
his dad
and when they say that oh the government
supports them and everything and i
remember at the time i was studying and
they said oh you know you get extra
money for being a single parent but they
want to know who the dad is and i said
no take your money
take your money it's not a good
influence on my son take your money i'll
do it on my own but he always has good
role models yes and that's important
and that's important too many they make
too many single parents make it look so
hard you know
it's hard when you don't keep on it's
hard when you don't have to shut your
legs
well you don't know how to shut your
legs and you don't know how to get both
control of course it's going to be hard
now bearing in mind there's no excuses
i'm the exception to every rule there is
out there i'm the exception
any situation i can say i'm the
exception to everything so i'm a rarity
but i know a lot of single parents
and either for that with some of them
that are friends of mine because i was a
hard-working person i can afford for
them to have children and they're not
working but i couldn't afford for me to
have any more yes because i was
hard-working so i can't always say put
it on the men because at the end of the
day yeah you can say put a condom you
think that after getting pregnant on the
pill that i just relied on the pill i
just relied on the condom i was using
everything there was
you know me even if i had the injection
and they said it's 90 i'm still using
the condom even if i was on the pill i'm
still using a condom
so it's got to be down to the women yeah
because at the end of the day
a single parent with more than one child
for the same person
i can understand that but a single
parent with loads of little
i was going to say little nigglets
that's what that's just saying that's in
my head
yeah what was it it's not noses yeah
but the little babies yeah
and you got loads of them running around
i remember i grew up with a girl and and
she was like the black version of
angelina jolie i saw her
and
every single nationality you see she
slept with
maybe to try them out
you know and they were all she never had
two kids that resembled each other and
they were all hers
so she didn't discriminate and at the
end of the day and you're saying that
i'm playing devil's advocate here
because
i've got one child for my son's dad yes
guess how many children he's got my
son's the second another third guess how
many how many he he's got the father of
your child
oh boy i don't know 16. 16. okay wow
16. i was going to say eight
he's got 16.
so you're trying to tell me that all
right then the first one i think he was
at school and it was a school like there
was about at school the second one was
supposed to be my son but i knew i knew
different i knew there was another one
out there that's why i said third
because he's still trying to convince us
it's the second okay
all of his children know their parents
all of his children know their dad
you're trying to tell me that you've got
you see a man
and he's got two children a different
parent three children
how the hell are you going to get to the
woman who's had number 16
then he got married to somebody don't
have no children for him she can't
but you say i mean so you can't keep on
sometimes the women shut your legs it's
it's both i mean it takes your legs
because the women will go out there and
they will see a man and they think
always this and this but the difference
is it's 80 90 it's like it's most women
where it's a small percentage of men
yeah and so you're going to say
percentage of men that what sorry it's a
small percentage of men that that women
want and so that are doing that's what
i'm saying like it's such a small
percentage so when you say it's it's the
men too it's like yeah okay it's it's 5
ten whatever it is and then when you get
the children
i'm not sure i get what's being argued
against here
no who's to blame for like you know
single parents you know it's all
sometimes it's all about the women
that's all is it about the man to me to
me too and i think sometimes the single
parents they they yeah the women use it
they use the sympathy yeah to me it's to
me it's completely 50 50. like it's
literally to me it's to me it's
literally 50 i don't think it's 50 50.
as a single parent i don't think it's 50
feet i don't i mean if i go out there
and i father 16 kids
right
like that's on
how how is that not on me
because we're in control but how is it
what about the women as well yeah but
they're they're
it's on them
i don't know why i would be absolved
yeah of the fact that i've chosen to go
out there and do more control like we
can be you can get an iud it's 99
effective you don't have that
control we do
we do too as a pretty strong extent it's
not the women when they're pregnant like
if you want
like i'm not saying like like
you know i mean if if i wanted to have
16 kids i could have 16 kids but i
wanted to have zero why are women
choosing to have 16 children all right
then some of them have got five children
i could even just be just like if i were
a snake i could even be completely
deceptive about it like no no no no i've
got 14 no he wasn't i'm saying you could
as a man yeah as a kid you could i could
have do you have 12 kids out there
and go and have a 13th with another
she's not even aware about the of the
other 12 or whatever you can say uh
whatever you know even promise oh you
know we're going to we're going to do
this again
girls girl they know and this is what
irritates me is they'll they'll act like
they don't know they might not know that
like maybe 13 kids they might not know
but you know when a dude is sleeping
around you do and i i don't believe it
for a second when these girls say oh i
didn't know i found out the difference
between sleeping around and fathering or
just having a ton of kids i mean to me
it's to me it's a 50 50 thing i don't
know
some of them i mean they have like five
from one of these
90 yeah i'm with you there pearl
because and what makes it worse is that
they choose the bad men
and then they're proud of it at the time
and then when it doesn't work they blame
the men
you know either woman come up to me
worse isn't there anymore but she came
up to me with a baby and said
he's got a boy now
c is and i thought you already had two
girls
you're not with him
and
you're gonna approach me to say that
he's got a son
because i i'm the only one with one
and i thought to myself
why would you do that why would you even
go there and have more children
you know but all that all the women knew
all the women knew that he had all these
children they always they were always
nice no they always know and then they
blame him but he knows as well like i
don't understand why we are absorbing
all responsibility from the man he's had
i mean
we're in control of sex would you have a
child
he can control that as well yeah make
sure she's on the pill is she lies i was
on the tail different i was on the pill
yeah but that's different because you
were on the pill but it's like you
literally you you know that some you're
having sex could potentially have a
child yes you know that yes you didn't
do anything to make sure she stops this
happening how can you then have no
responsibility
i'm not i'm not disagree like yes
men have a part to play but i just think
it's more on the women because we have
control we are in control of birth if
you if you get pregnant you can get an
abortion men have no say in that so
until that's equal i can't say we're in
equally at fault
i think in terms of [ __ ] we have 41
forms of birth control what men have won
and we're also in control of the people
that we sleep with you can require they
wear a condom well that's even
misogynistic
no no no not developing a lot of birth
control for men when men are having no
they have trouble around these women
that's misogynistic
they've tried but it led to a lot of men
being sterilized so it's it's not
misogynistic there's a new one they're
working that's it's
that's just a simple biological equation
because men produce millions of sperm
every day women produce one egg per
month it's easier to control one egg
than it is millions and millions of
sperm so that's just a biological
function that's why it's like that way
it's not because
you know scientists are mean and
misogynistic and want to kind of put it
all on women it's just that it's
it's easier that way which is kind of
you know just got a barrier you can just
have a barrier um
but
it's just a tough thing to work out also
yeah when it comes to women we know we
know the days that we can get pregnant
we can be a little bit more risque
with it and be like okay i may not have
to take the pill today i may not have to
go get a plan b we know when the peak
time for us to get pregnant that's why
i think it'd be more so on the women
than the men i'm not giving off
i'm gonna i'm gonna be maybe maybe i'm
just gonna be like old school here but
look we all we all know how babies are
made man woman we we all know how this
process works
um
number one i you know some people won't
like me saying this but i don't think
you should be having sex with people who
you're mortified with the concept of
having a child with exactly right like
if the thought of having a child with
that person is going to be like the end
the end of the world or somehow then
maybe you shouldn't be and this goes for
i'm saying this for men too all right
i'm saying this for men too if the
thought of that woman getting pregnant
by you is makes you want to run to the
hills maybe bro you should you know be
be careful there
um so you know these conversations
sometimes frustrate me because it's like
it's it's kind of you know it's like
look let's just let's just be mature be
mature about it and make good decisions
and don't be don't be reckless we have
all there's different options out there
um
everyone know anyone who knows me knows
i'm straight up pro-life i don't think
that executing the baby is the uh
is the way forward at all morally um
but there are many things you can do to
prevent that and not get to that stage
um
so i think i think i think
i don't want to let men off the hook on
this at all because
we both both sexes
need to just be responsible and sensible
with this like sex is not i know that
modern society
wants to push out and indoctrinate
everyone with this message that it's
just you know some completely random
inconsequential
fun activity like ping pong or going to
the you know or whatever but it's like
it's got very serious potential lifelong
ramifications
um and it's how we all got here right
it's like it's a it's a major thing and
with something that's that
has can have such potential
ramifications uh you know people should
not treat it so carelessly i think
that's the truth of it it shouldn't be
treated so carelessly and recklessly and
i think if
you know and and by the way
people always knew this like this isn't
some new i'm not saying something new
here people knew this forever which is
why there were certain
behaviors that were frowned upon or
promoted and so on and so forth it's not
just trying to be mean to everyone or to
cramp crap cramp down on their liberty
um it's like well children are
the product of this yeah i just i just
think that
birth control should be banned oh wow
you should be taken off the market i
agree okay
[Laughter]
had 14 children yeah what do you think
about that
if i say my old stepdad he's my late
stepdad had 14 children now i said to
you my son's dad had 16
and my late stepdad
had 14. interesting
the only difference is he had 13 from
one woman okay
but and
the only reason why it's able to
progress like that i believe because of
birth control
can i ask what you guys mean by that by
saying you think birth control you
should be banned like and i just i
wonder if you put that on that guy
so basically saying that a woman should
not be able to decide to terminate a
child
oh i see i didn't say that no she said
that's what both countries said
no i don't know
some traditional catholics oh some
traditional catholics and they tell you
about birth control you want to get
pregnant you have sex otherwise you know
when you're when you're ovulating and
you work around it because proper
catholics don't believe in child can
birth control
and um my son's my
my late stepdad
his former partner was catholic they
have 13 children so every time they were
going to have sex they knew that if we
have it at this time or there's a
possibility because in those days i
didn't know about ovulating you're going
to get pregnant so if every woman and
every man went out there especially the
women because they're the ones that have
to carry the baby if you knew that every
time you had sex there's a possibility
you got pregnant there'd be less sex
where would i stand as an atheist he
doesn't want kids
yeah
as an atheist you don't want kids i just
can't have sex or just have to work
around what i'm going to be relating yes
if i have normal periods that be well
you can just work your way around it wow
yeah just tie your two
yeah i'm
[Music]
also because also because i am pro-life
and i don't want that would just lead to
it
that would lead to a massive spike in
abortions and i think that would be
there's no abortions there's nothing no
there are there are more abortions after
the development of birth control than
before i think we're talking about
things in an ideal world i think we're
forgetting about
self-determination you can say to
someone you shouldn't do that that's his
naivety well i just say as a parent of a
teenager going don't go out and do drugs
and have sex they're going to do it
anyway and that's what we're like a
society we're going to go out and have
sex we're going to do it with you but
the difference is with birth control you
take away the consequence and i just
think there's ramifications when you
take away the consequence if you look at
after the development of birth control
like the chart um of when birth control
was introduced and then the divorce rate
in society it's like literally the same
but if we take away birth control i
wouldn't what would happen to the
abortion rates exactly i think women
would be i think women would just be
more careful with who they slept with
but then that's the pressure on the
woman yeah that's that's the truth
okay you don't okay you don't think it's
okay okay okay you don't you don't like
okay okay okay you don't you don't you
don't think it's good that women should
be careful with who we sleep with yes no
i think okay okay
right right so because you said it's too
much pressure it's too much pressure to
like oh my gosh like i can't obviously
yeah
guys can we understand that women get
horny exactly
you guys are okay with that concept you
know like i am horny outside of my
ovulation period
birth control so you shouldn't have sex
no no no no i'm saying the ovulation is
going
i think it goes back to what zooby said
to not sleep with someone where it's
horrible if you have a child with them
of course
right so you said it's too much pressure
like people used to get like pregnant
back in the day before birth control
they just have a shotgun wedding and
figure it out yeah because it wasn't the
end of the problem is that that that
that cat that cat is out the bag now
right so
in the past in a much more traditional
and a much more religious society
the answer to a
you know
pre-a pre-marital
pregnancy
simple answer
get married and that's still that's
still a good answer for a lot of people
as far as i'm concerned
however with the way that marriage has
changed it there have been too many
changes
to then go and go okay let's ban birth
control now
and you've already let all these other
cats out the back to me that's just
that's just chaos i just want to see
what happens
i
i i feel like girls would make better
decisions if there was a consequence i
don't i think you just get a huge spike
in abortions yeah yeah i think you'd get
a gigantic spike in it no no we should
ban that too let's ban both okay well
then that's different i'm much more in
favor of yeah
i don't i don't think that i i know i
think that because that that outward
still exists so what would realistically
happen is people would still just go
around and prosecute their sex or
whatever
because they'll prosecute them
send them to jail
i thought i was conservative
i would do jail time
i think there has to be consequences i
think women
i i made a comment of the day on this
post and i got a lot of backlash about i
don't think it's difficult to not get
pregnant yes you're correct yeah yeah
i've never found it difficult to not get
pregnant i've never been pregnant
because i've taken my birth control yes
um but yeah i think that in an ideal
world birth control wouldn't need to
exist abortions would need to exist i am
uh pro-abortion but
point being we're not in an ideal world
we're in a society people that have free
will self-determinations their own
environments they will never conform to
those things it will not stop it
happening people want to have sex let's
try time let's try
we've got a bunch of horny people in
this world and they're not going to stop
[ __ ] because abortion and and the
like is is you know banned like
i just i i feel like when people like
thomas sowell always talks about it like
when people face the consequences of
their decisions they make better
decisions yeah generally generally
speaking but as we let's try it as
we can see
as we can see this is just often not the
not the case though right as we were
talking about people having you know
dozens yeah exactly
yeah but they're a lot of times they're
incentivized to do so
yeah like because like nick cannon all
those girls are taken care of yeah yeah
so so it's not like a con they didn't
get a consequence they got a payout
yeah yeah people are generally going to
do what they're what they're
incentivized to do you know and i think
one of the big problems we have in in
modern western society is that on a lot
of different issues on a lot of things
the incentives are just broken
right bad activities are
incentivized and good positive wholesome
things are often disincentivized or
sometimes even punished
and
i i don't i don't think it's good i
think you know long term that's going to
cause
that's going to cause a lot of chaos and
these things are generational and the
more millions of children you have
growing up in certain circumstances and
modeling certain behaviors it's just
going to get exponentially worse
with each generation so
you know i'm just big i'm big i'm very
big on personal responsibility and
accountability
and i think it's much better to
make good decisions
up front
rather than
you know
mess up in all these very consequential
ways and then now you've downstream now
the line you know everyone everyone has
to clean up the mess you know it's not
just an individual because we all impact
our societies that we live in
that's my thought i stand by it banned
birth control over an abortion
[Laughter]
i actually think men are more like
irresponsible when it comes to
reproduction so i actually think it
should be the other way right more
irresponsible yeah they're more
irresponsible women are more responsible
40
30 of women that have had abortion no 40
of women that have had abortions have
had two or more come on yeah but they're
more like they're more men that have a
lot of baby mamas
no they're not yes they are no 40
only 40 of men have even reproduced
historically
so throughout history most men like
getting to reproduce was a privilege
like women aren't most men aren't even
having sex like one out of three men
under 30 or virgins
one out of one out of three men under 30
are either virgins or haven't had sex in
the past year
uh so that's not true
is this that's in america yeah it's no
it's here too it's in the west single
there's no no because no but this is
right no it's it's okay one and three
it's because three men under 30.
there's a whole there's a whole group of
men you guys just don't see
because you guys are pretty girls and so
you're not going to notice the guy
that's like working at tesco involuntary
celibacy does not exist for women
it's a male 1
like the reason that women like the
reason that women think men are cheating
or think that are trash is because
literally we're all sleeping with the
same one yeah yeah because like women
women only swim the number one way
people are meeting nowadays is social
media and and you know on social media
you can be more honest
not social media dating apps and so you
know women only swipe right between five
to twenty percent of the time even even
if we doubled it let's say let's say
it's forty percent of the time like
that's still sixty percent of men that
no one like no one wants
yeah and but i still think the desired
men
the ones in this ten percent
they should
they should give them some
responsibility because they agree with
you they keep having to do that
legally legally they do though they're
on the hook for child support like the
difference is like men actually have a
consequence where women don't because
whatever bad decision we make we're
always paid out
like so if we get pregnant we can get
child support or we can get married to
the guy and take half in a divorce we
aren't even paying child support only
like the rich ones like the ones
literally from tesco they're not paying
it right
women okay
women women typically don't sleep with
broke men and if they do they're usually
very no no if they let me let me let me
if they do they're usually very
attractive so the incentive for the girl
is to get good genes from the guy
basically man you know what maybe maybe
those are
those religions had a point you know
maybe maybe they'd work this stuff out
thousands of years ago and we're like
you know what people should get married
and have sex in that relationship and
have children in that relationship and
that's just clean and it works
i'm just saying you don't think it's
better now what's better you don't think
relationships are better now
oh my
oh my yeah
man there's a lot of you know
i i think as a society with a lot of
things sometimes we're
we're way too quick to
assume that an old idea is a bad idea
right there are bad old ideas and
there's lots of bad new ideas as well i
think we started the first hour and a
half of the conversation with a bad new
idea
um you know but i i think we want to
look towards what worked whether whether
an idea or concept is new or old you
know i think if something
works and has a clear function and
benefit then i generally think it's it's
foolish to
throw it away or jettison it or not cons
not at least consider it in the context
of potential
ideas and solutions because some of
these problems are age-old
for thousands and thousands of years
this conversation it wasn't happening
like this on a podcast
this conversation is always modern today
because people have always been horny
like people have always had sex drives
like we've always been
you know we exist because of it
literally um but it's always like
happening
so
um was it henry the eighth because he
wanted to marry another woman so he
changed the laws to say that he can get
married again so actually it's always
men
men
okay i just went to carnival to do
interviews yeah you're telling me that
men are the problem when these women are
walking around in thongs
in public
oh that's like okay so yeah
what do you mean that's a whole
different spectrum
now you're not supposed to look sexy
i mean i you can look sexy and keep it
classy like you know there's a i think
there's a difference between like you
know a little leg a little cleavage and
like i don't know a thong
so it's your fault that you had sex with
you because you were wearing a thong
i know i don't understand
i i i'm saying that women are in control
of sex men are in control of
relationships yeah they're both in
control of both no
control of sex too you can decide
you know what i don't want to have sex
with you i think pearl is talking about
the ultimate decision
right that ultimately
it's you know
god forbid you know freaking grape
um you know ultimately
the women are the gatekeepers of sex
yeah right
um
which is why
if you want to see the oppo this is why
like gay dudes just you know have way
way way higher numbers of sexual because
females not involved right like it's
just dudes being dudes and
they go do their you know do their
things it's very different um so yeah
women women are ultimately the
gatekeepers of sex and i think that when
it comes to
relationships and commitment and i think
this is the point pearl is making
men tend to be the ultimate
gatekeepers of that of how they want
that relationship to proceed if they
want that to be okay cool like this is
exclusive or this is you know
a marriage or what what whatever it is
you know obviously with a marriage
obviously a woman has to say yes to a
proposal
um but yeah i think i think the general
point there is true but i think when it
comes to the responsibility
of sex and the responsibility of what is
downstream from sex
i put that 50 50. 90 10. oh i put that
50 90 10. yeah i put that i think all of
them
yeah i i i have i have concerns about
like letting any sex even if it is my
own
my own male sex off the hook i'll give
you
a lot a lot of
a lot of bad behavior um maybe 25.
no honestly honestly i think it's not
not 20 20.
and i think it's i do think it sends the
wrong message to young dudes out there
like oh okay well it's on the women so
i'm just going to go and be
reckless and spread my seed and sew my
wild oats in a very reckless manner
and then it's up to them to deal with
the messy potential consequences of that
i don't i don't think that's the message
we want to be putting out there
my personal opinion
and as a woman in the society
i actually used to like sex but now all
men want to do is have sex that's it you
speak to a guy that's all he wants to
talk about
i'll be kidding why because guys want to
have so if you were 300 pounds guys
wouldn't talk to you no but then but the
point is the point is a lot more women
just want to talk have conversation all
men want to do nowadays is sick guys
that don't like you
like that's all they want to do guys
that don't like you just want to have
sex yeah but you can like me and don't
just talk to me well he probably doesn't
he probably doesn't like you if he
doesn't want to talk to you no but what
i'm saying is you i know you like me
right but why is it that no you want to
have sex all the time
it's actually
annoying go away
yeah i mean because they're they're guys
you know this is this is why some
some like the hardcore feminist types
that's part of why they make themselves
unattractive
what do you mean
to not get as much male attention
right they they literally will make
themselves whether it's through their
haircut the way they dress how many
pounds they weigh or whatever they will
make themselves less physically
desirable
consciously or subconsciously in order
to
have less men approaching them and
dealing with them
which is
a bit of a sidebar but it's an
interesting point compared to just given
what you were saying yeah yeah okay yeah
i'm gonna i'm gonna take a second to
read super chats then i think we're
going to close out the show so if you
have any final thoughts you want to like
speak your piece on
um you know feel free so um 67 big mel
loved the show anthony guzman
interesting to
interesting you got to touch this topic
i would love to hear more of this um
daffool 101 in australia there's a small
group of adults who are trying to tell
people they now identify as children and
have the right to sleep with children
every point that the lady is talking
about transgender these adults are
saying too what if that was about your
child johnny b forget the physical
differences should men be allowed to
take advantage of women
only school and government programs um
ike though hal guerra um gay is a
preference you can like chocolate or
oatmeal cookies trans culture wants you
to accept that oatmeal can be chocolate
and vice versa
yes all based on feelings
jb fm 101 it
when her real viewpoints came out and
she quickly changes this girl is the
definition of she babes go think for
yourself and then come back auntie jenny
i'm sorry we can't save her matt butcher
rapunzel i figured you out you're
trolling us and you're killing it girl
there has to be an award for this oh
wait let me refresh this so i can see
the newer super chats
sorry i realize i didn't refresh the
page
okay guys make sure you like the video
um that is the most important metric
that youtube uses to push out these
lives so if you like this stream make
sure you
like it because a like is free and all
the super chats are going towards an 8k
camera okay mgtow by logic you're
awesome tallulah keep it up alistar
horton men mostly look for sex
men look mostly for sex from women
because it is one of the few things the
independent man
most women
want can't get on their own mgtow by
logic i can't a king once did x ergo all
men are trash also my dad was trash so
all men are trash low value women um
gabrielle
gabrielle turman 50 50 is confusing
blame and effort it takes equal effort
but women have so much opportunity of
choice just don't pick the guy who
leaves and don't pick the guy you know
will leave
daniel cole i make 20 hours i i make 20
hours and pay 1500 a month in child
support what what is this only rich guys
pay child support zero guyer
think about it pearl think about this
pearl holds two fruits one is an apple
and the other is an orange if you dip
both to be opposite colors
can you call the red painted orange
apple and the orange color apple orange
samuel tagan sexual liberation and birth
control equals single moms villain
eliminating birth control equals no hot
bro summers um other worldly oddities tv
medusa medusa birth control is not the
same as abortion black is panther zubi
uses the same argument women use was
black as panther zubi uses the same
argument women use like there aren't
enough women ceos when only a few men
are actually ceos in the first place
only a few men impregnate a majority of
women why is zubi placing 50 why is zubi
placing 50 on men as a whole
joshua zubi says you shouldn't have kids
with someone you're mortified of
procreating with but women control
access to sex not men mgtow by logic
women are more responsible because they
make the final choice at choice to half
a man or not duh wake up casual hand
does look up the documentary the
vanishing black family from 18 from 1986
it explains what happened and where the
single mother crisis pretty much started
jc if the relationship breaks down i
only blame the man mgtow by logic
a man doesn't get a woman pregnant she
gets herself pregnant by her own choice
she chooses who goes in not men her body
her choice remember doug mpa
damn zooby's sounding like a simp this
hurts
90 free toepay
for all the men when is the last time
you asked a girl to do anything and she
did it with no bargains the the second
you know you can get out of the dishes
you won't do it matt butcher rapunzel
please i know you're young
please i know you're young but shut your
mouth and open your ears for a year and
just listen you monopolize the show this
is why we can't have nice things
villain237 shout out to pearl zubie and
tate you guys are great king zendaya
zubi stop enabling the partnership idea
joseph metzler
in the u.s women make less money than
men yet hold almost all credit card debt
two-thirds of student loan debt is held
by women same with car loans
men save and invest at a higher level
marriage causes divorce zooby you want
to get married are you crazy bro doug
mpa average black women in the u.s have
a net worth of less than five dollars
have the most consumer debt the most
student loan debt highest eviction rates
all of it wendell coven why do women
feel they get extra points for being a
responsible adult you're you're an adult
that pays the bills we'll be
thane
mtra auntie keep cooking these young
delusional children we love you das
token e30 women will never be us we
build we use our hands 90 free topay
locks you proved why women can't be
alpha you almost ran away because of
words there's no such thing as strong
women jesse peterson hi auntie maury men
aren't looking for for partners by the
way in a heterosexual relationship i'm
leader and the head of the household as
a man my woman or wife is my second in
command above our children if we have
any mara s both genders are not entitled
to each other's money james shark pearl
your next topic should be beta males are
dangerous because they enable the toxic
behaviors of modern day women 67 big
mouth when you remove god and standards
you let the devil in matt butcher
rapunzel you are young and in denial and
showing poor social skills auntie pearl
jess and zubi are being more
accommodating please watch this back and
with an open mind and improve yourself
hater please tell the weak faith that
her faith is most certainly weak she
can't cope when the attention isn't on
her um otherworldly oddities tv you lost
your faith when you went to china your
words tony as a christian her faith is
weak it's easier to not follow god
lawrence i identify as jess and pearl's
husbands the sister wives now
now how to lose
now how delusional does that sound um
tim nerith pearl castle coming in hot
let's go
mr missing 44. you got a stage when you
stop thinking exactly the problem 90
free tope women are too dumb for
hypotheticals prove me wrong
calico loving just in that hoodie
long shot she's making a point you are a
choice you could just ignore what you
didn't recognize or whatever kane the
the woman really doesn't understand
understand objective reality she keeps
trying to pretend she doesn't grasp
simple concepts then some modern women
are
oh no that's a big word some modern
women have been
capitalistically mined as echo
have you seen these words
as economic cogs tax contributors
economic slaves the attempt to divorce
the feminine cell from biology is
obscene the plethora of 35 plus women on
tick tock crying is a post-awakening is
now the norm medic braids will always
stay open-minded
braids will stay open-minded till it has
a negative long-term effect in our life
directly blue baggins hurt after your
feelings sometimes it's better to be
quiet and let people think you're full
then open your mouth and prove them
right mr missing listening bro when
caitlyn jenner won woman of the year
that was a dub for the so-called
patriarchy um maurice ainf pearl what in
the world where in the world are you
finding all these second generation
nigerian women from
other worthy oddities tv having a
different category for trans people
still wouldn't work a woman that's trans
to man would still lose to a man that's
trans to woman
67 big mel loved the show anthony guzman
interesting to see you touch this topic
i would love to hear more of this
davpool 101 in australia there's a small
group of adults who are trying however
this one okay
okay um so thank you guys all for coming
good panel this is fun yay
see i feel like the claps just make it
better
um so why don't we start on that side
and you can give your final thoughts
anything you want to speak your piece on
go on
and where they can find you
to each to their own really like
everyone has their own opinion that's
all i can say um
we agree to disagree really
um you can find me on instagram and on
youtube it is christabelle so it dot is
dot christabel
sweet blackberry
i'm what i want to say we're just
listening to those comments it just
shows
how
misogynistic our society still is just
because he actually just said
it should be 50 50. like we are still
not in that age where we want to put
responsibility on men and look at the
way people are written
can i make a point there firstly i think
it's interesting that the people who
commented those i noticed all almost all
of their usernames had like um you know
mgtow in there there was the guy who was
had this explicitly anti-marriage
username
um you know so there's certainly a lot
of red pill rage out there and you know
i think it's you know for people who are
deep into the red pill
when it goes very and by the way like uh
you know i've been familiar with this
concept since i was a i was a teenager
so for all these people who just
discovered the red pill recently like
you know don't don't try to school me on
this um
it can end up over correcting and
becoming almost like a male version of
the modern feminism that we that we
dislike where
men start having this victim mentality
and wanting to put just like these
feminists are blaming men for everything
and saying the patriarchy is the
patriarch it's everything it's men it's
never them
men need to be careful that they don't
over correct into this same mentality of
trying to absolve ourselves of our
masculine duties and responsibilities
and overall ethics and putting all the
blame on women and females i i say the
exact same thing to feminists so i i
don't want to see that over correction
in the in the other direction where it
just becomes this very hard line
ideology and and becomes resentful you
know becomes resentful just like when
people go too deep into feminism they
often end up becoming misandrious and
having an animosity and resentment
towards towards men it can happen the
other way around when guys go really
really deep especially like the sort of
new red pill stuff and they end up you
know being
so
deep into the philosophy and ideology
that they're not really thinking of them
themselves individually and there's
people i think it's always been like
that like even if you look at into the
biblical um term like a woman was not
allowed to be a pastor a woman has to be
silent in the church i think it's always
been where a woman is supposed to be
subordinate and this is what's happening
these comments are just showing
society's reaction to women help me like
sorry help mate
in the bible
yeah yeah does my hands help me i know
but that's the thing like why is she
this little helper like she's just
supposed to be in the background why
can't she lead why can't she do that i
think
again to talk to my point a a woman can
a woman can
the point is
that that is traditionally a masculine
role and this often comes down to what
both each each gender is attracted to as
i said before
a woman can have that position and want
to roll and even want to be the
breadwinner and so on and so forth
and she can find a guy who will be happy
with that and will be happy to assume
that position i'm just saying that's
going to be a more feminized man
i mean there's nothing
i'm just that's just the reality of it
because you're going to get the
complimentary aspect so if a man is very
very masculine in a traditional sense
he's likely to attract and be compatible
with a very very feminine women if a
woman is coming in playing more the
traditional masculine role
then a man who wants to also play that
traditional masculine they're they're
going to clash they're not they're not
going to get along well with each other
and i think to me that's always been the
problem because i'm a leader like i like
to lead in a relationship but also but i
also like my mental lead no that you
won't
i'm just saying that what i'm trying to
say exactly because people keep saying
it's not gonna work in their head that
no it can't work it's not i can't let it
leave
something it's not just it's not just in
our head it's in our biological wiring
it's in our instinct so just like you
are are you do you prefer taller man
yeah if you're taller than me yes okay
right so just like that's hardwired in
you biologically even if you wanted to
like force yourself to try to be more
attracted to men shorter than you and
you can't biologically it's the same as
a man in wanting to
play a certain role in a relationship
and to be a leader to an extent it's
hardwired in us it's not just a societal
opinion or a construct allow me you
don't allow me to have certain control
of certain aspects in the relationship
i'm already turned off anyway i could be
so attracted to you and as soon as
you're like i've got to control the
finances i've got to do this i'm like
you know what boy
i feel like you just want the best of
everything you just want
why can't i why can't why can't i have
okay why can't men have pure virgins
because they're not having sex with
women so they can't be virgins i'm
saying like like women bring less to the
table than ever we're less pure we're
older when we get married and so it's
like you don't see zoo bee on this panel
saying like why isn't everyone 22
like
and so and so it's like
like you just want everything
yeah i do yeah yeah yeah i'm going to
let's start fighting for women's rights
minority rights okay
i am a walking people naturally hate me
because i'm so against what society is
no i think people if a woman can do it
all right
i think i think it's because you're
argumentative i don't think it's because
you're against what society is i think
the backlash you get is because you're
argumentative and you interrupt no no
that's got nothing to do with it
can we not be insulting again
you're not annoyed
i think you're actually a very
compassionate person
but i think that that compassion is
sometimes blinding you to certain
realities i also just think you're young
right and i'm not trying to be this
patronizing person right but when as
you get older some of the things will
right even between the eight for me
between the ages of 25 and 35 the way
certain things that like my parents used
to say or that i used to hear the way
some of it started like clicking and i
was like oh okay
that that's why it was like that or you
know you just experienced 10 more years
of life and you interact with thousands
and thousands of more people and you see
okay that's why certain things are
certain ways it's not just because
people are mean and nasty and want to
like press down on women or no it's
because men don't want to accept that
women we can make our own money we know
you can we we can build we don't need
your money
okay so
why do you like so why do you even want
to get married you said you want to get
married why because i love men i
actually like me why i get married you
know what that actually this is a point
i've always been wanting to make i've
come to realization that men don't
actually like women that's not true they
they just see us
oh you see us all you see us is for sex
no
if you respected us
is this how i've come across in the past
i mean that's why you're getting hate
though that's why you're getting hate
because you have a bit of a balance i'm
mostly getting love i'm just saying i
think there's a couple guys in the chat
who have what i call red pill rage yeah
but as soon as you start talking about
the balance
there was rage
and that's because i do think
men just see us as sex objects we
generally don't respect us i don't think
men respects us they respect their other
fellow men they see a man and think oh
he's strong yeah you can do this you see
a woman
all i want to do is
i i think if i were
i think if i were making a statement
that brought and generalized about women
you wouldn't like it would you say do
you have brothers do you have cousins
boy cousins yeah
is your father still in your life yeah
okay
would you say that
there since you're clumping all of them
together you say they're they just want
females
like i will say that because a lot of
the time i will have to even check my
brother to say why are you not allowing
her to make a decision it's her life i
will check men even if i love you i also
have to understand that women need to be
respected it's not happening we look at
this
women do you check women for not being
the things that men want you know so if
a girl is like being a hoe will you
check her
yeah yeah yeah as much as i check men so
when she was talking about the story
about the woman that had had 16 kids and
the man that had 16 kids to me both of
them hoes i don't see her as a [ __ ] no
i'm sorry both of them need to be held
responsibly like responsible and i think
that's what's not happening we keep
slut-shaming women but a man he's you
know he's a giant you know women love
him we're not putting responsibilities
on men and i think it's a problem i
think that men have all the
responsibility
again like men pay for everything every
decision they make
they should i don't think they should
but i'm saying like we're not putting
any of the responsibility i'm saying
we're not putting any of the
responsibility you're saying we're not
putting the responsibility on men i'm
saying they have all of it because
there's a consequence when they do
something there's not for women so if
anything you could argue it more the
other way around
do you know what i think is is really
really confusing with this point where
we are right now in modern society is
people really want to have the cake and
eat it too people want to be
traditional take to kind of cherry pick
some of the traditional elements and the
gender roles and then completely have
like this equalist
total equality view in other places and
kind of cherry pick from all these
things and these things don't they don't
work they don't work together they don't
they don't work in harmony you can't
have
like
all of it right if it's like okay we're
gonna just treat men and women
exactly the same with very few
accommodations no special treatment and
so on we're not gonna have chivalry and
you know men and women women and men
women and children get off the get off
the boat the sinking boat first right
you you can't in a truly equalistic
society you can't have those
accommodations but i do already agree
with that yeah i think a man if he says
i don't want to propose to you babe yeah
i understand because you know what rings
are expensive yeah
you know what i mean i already think
about that but the reality is that men
and women due to our biology we're still
wired to be attracted to the same things
that our ancestors were so
even though so generally speaking even
though yes women women can make money in
fact under the age of 30
in most cases in many western countries
now women actually out earn men on
average right it's not until they get
into their 30s and oftentimes start
families that it switches because
they're the ones who have get pregnant
and breastfeed and so on it makes sense
um
but where where where was i going with
this
um
i lost my i lost my train of thought
there it's a little bit a little bit
later we want to eat our cake and have
it yeah
yeah they they don't the these these
things are not
they're they're not compatible
they're they're not compatible you can't
be on one hand saying
strong independent woman got my own
money whatever oh but also i still want
the man to be
taller and make even more money than i
do and to lead but i also want to lead
and i want
it it just doesn't
it contradicts too much i agree
do follow me i'm actually lovely
she actually had a very funny episode
with castilla i actually really liked
that video it was really good
um you guys should check it out on
youtube too
auntie and jenny
bring on tradition
save the world with tradition mm-hmm
that's why
and we're starting your channel soon
yeah so you can find me
yeah it'll you'll you'll see guys you'll
see i'll post it
go ahead i don't have any more final
thoughts i'm just kind of resounding of
whatever everyone's been saying
um
but what i will do is plug my instagram
um to go back to my initial statement of
me putting my foot on my head perhaps
in that portal so my instagram is emily
amelia rose that's my final fourth feat
for the evening
um jess you want to go and then soon we
can go yeah um
great panel i love going back and forth
with people
it's it's fun
so just the intense conversations i
enjoy it enjoy seeing people's uh
uh differences and understanding
where they come from i think everybody
should be able to
do that in any setting that they're in
um
or you can find me you can find me on
instagram and youtube at uh your girl
justly
both of them coincide pearl you'd be
happy yeah
awesome and thank you for coming by the
way you're welcome i've been following
zoopy for a minute so i was really
excited to have you on
it's it's been an honor thank you paul
for hosting it thank you for everyone
who's been a part of this i think this
has genuinely been a very positive
discussion i think these conversations
are very very necessary in society and
we should all be having more of them and
where people can find me i'm on all
social media at zooby music zuby music
check out teamzubi.com we just launched
the new website and you can follow me
everywhere you can find my podcast on
all platforms real talk with zooby you
can find my music on itunes apple music
spotify all the usual places just search
my name zooby and you will find me
okay guys um a couple announcements
before we end the show don't forget to
subscribe to the channel as you already
know if you've watched two or more lives
and you don't subscribe we have beef so
hit that subscribe button like the video
on your way out also follow our two
clips channel sign up for our
memberships if you want to be part of
the chat next show um if you want to see
what the penthouse looks like sign up
for our 10 memberships and our third
membership you connect with us on social
media fourth membership it's a
one-on-one call with me once a month dm
eddie if you want to get on the show the
link to his instagram is in the
description thank you guys for watching
and we will talk to you next time
bye